told
[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect yo what's up everybody I
am Thomas dop YOLO I'm with my co-host
Mar O'Neal what's up folks this is the
dope as usual podcast we here to talk
about life drugs promis accomplishments
and today we're talking about a whole
lot of in between and some drugs maybe
some violence and some crap maybe some
journalism guys today's episode I'm very
excited this is trap L Ross thank you
for being here from across the water you
came out over here yeah man I'm over
here it's crazy like it feels surreal I
just got here last night and like I feel
like I've stepped into the GTA Lobby yep
Live In the Flesh bro I just I just
spawned and except there's all sorts
going on man you guys were just telling
me there's some app that I can use to
find the local crimes the best thing I
ever said do I have to be a citizen to
get the citizen app that was best thing
you ever I've loved it no you don't and
you're going to it's going to blow your
mind so before we started guys we told
him that uh you you asked about the 10
freeway like it just burned like someone
just burned a section of it down I
didn't know freeways could burn to be
honest I the same thing it's concrete I
thought did I see like a few months back
was there a freeway that collapsed or
something like that was there a freeway
collaps oh the one is that what happened
Big Sir that was like a Landslide
Landslide damn didn't like people a
couple people died in that right like oh
man I don't know
it's it's terrifying driving that
stretch cuz you're on the side you're on
a the edge of a mountain on the side of
the ocean oh man Scot looks like yeah
it's like that like it doesn't even feel
like America anymore up there by Big Sir
that's why I get bummed out that that
happened because it's been closed for so
long now you can't go up there you know
without taking the long way you guys are
going to have no roads left soon man
it's going to be back to dirt tracks and
like buggies crazy dude buggies damn
horse and CPE type Vibes out here man
wait real quick you said before before
we started you have sophisticated petty
crime in the UK and over here we have
GTA Lobby style
stuff the differences that I see is you
remember America is your curriculum at
second grade is like our ninth yeah yeah
it's not it's true America is very like
yo just dig a ditch what are you doing
work at McDonald's bro no educ so from
here to there you you've been here for
one day I've been here for one day man I
have been here before but like you know
what I'm saying I feel like every time I
come back here Society has collapsed
just a little bit more you know what I
mean like you guys got freeways on fire
now I mean what am I I'm seeing all
kinds of like just crazy La crime I
think last time I was here there was
some crazy like police shootout on the
highway or something like I I see a guy
getting like rammed off the road or
something Rob saw that yeah bro crazy
stuff going on man this place is it is
legit like I understand why they set GTA
here yeah cuz this is it it's like they
have the code to take all the stars off
every couple seconds like yo shoot
somebody oh you're fine no more stars
it's like remember the old GTA and you
could do the cheat where it was like
everybody's just trying to kill each
other yes it's like will try to shoot
you turn that [__] on yeah that's
exactly what it is bro like the homeless
like making all the homeless guys have
weapons and they're after you now or
something uh I mean I don't get too
crazy but like two years ago some guy
got speared speared a homeless guy made
a spear and threw it through a guy's
chest as he was walking to work and
killed him like he made a spear to throw
killed this guy imagine that bro you're
walking to work and the homeless guy
throws a spear at your chest you got to
just think like bro I could not have
seen this
coming how could how could you have
avoided bro there's no then you don't go
out the door and be like I got to watch
out for Spears today I got to make sure
like I got my spear vest on it's kind of
it's kind of crazy because if you think
about it as you're dying going for real
spear you see you're just dead I got no
point of reference for how to deal with
this in in the Lexicon of like how to
deal with situations I was like no one
really prepared me for like spear attack
no I feel like I'm ready like for you
know what I'm saying shooting stabbings
in the UK we got like hell stabbings and
knife crime and [__] yeah yeah that's
our thing that's like shot and stab yeah
fact and I know I'll die faster but
seeing that night like oh no is that
because like guns are not allowed at all
yeah yeah guns are way harder to get in
the UK like they're still around they're
still the thing that's crazy cuz
obviously I cover a lot of like gang
politics kind of stuff both in the US
and in the UK and in the UK it's like
guns are still around but it's like it's
like an event if someone pulls out a gun
and shoots something up that's like
international well national news like
there was a shooting at like a funeral
at the start of this year like someone
did a driveby on a funeral like these
two gangs were going at it and like
that's unprecedented that was like you
know prime ministers on the news talking
about it like crazy whereas you guys if
there's a shooting or stabbing you a Joe
Biden ain't going to ain't going to make
a comment on that that's every day [__]
basically what you're saying is we [__]
in the left you guys and we should have
just been like be be English leave this
land and look what happened we still got
taxed we still have taxes you know what
though your taxes are better though UK
taxes UK taxes are pretty harsh we got
crazy taxes yeah if you're earning good
money man UK it's like 45% I think over
here like 30 something C is like the
worst in America though right you guys
got the most I don't know what it works
out at cuz I was I was kind of thinking
like maybe I should move to Miami and
like cut my taxes a little something
like 30 30% or 27 or something Miami
English 45% bro what's the equivalent of
like minimum wage in UK I think it's
like oh man I forget I think it's
something like 12 pounds an hour it's
higher I think it's higher than is it
but isn't California a minimum wage
higher 12 pounds an hour sounds crazy
that's prob like 14 bucks or something
yeah pounds and the Euro's uh almost to
the dollar right now yeah we don't have
the Euro so we got the pound still we
never we never joined Europe we were
always like skeptical and like guys are
just the top of the food chain over like
no no no yeah you want to leave go
[__] make it across the ocean no we
have different money here that's [__]
crazy cuz we don't trust Europe this is
the thing about British people is we're
always we kind of see ourselves as
better than Europeans and we kind of
don't trust them like the like English
people hate the French basically like we
don't we don't really rock with the
French so it's kind of like they have
all the they were doing all the Euro and
the Germans and we were just kind of
like nah leave us out of that and it all
kind of went to [__] so we we made the
right move in the end yeah you guys
serve hell of French food in England
though kind of yeah but like English
food sucks you know it's notorious like
beige flavorless like mashed potatoes I
mean I I got a soft spot for English
food cuz it's like very nourishing and
like I don't know the food in America is
lit but you guys just you guys way too
much bro there portions here it's like
two meals in the UK it's crazy bro I put
on hella weight when I come here really
so it's coming bro I'm I'm ready to just
eat for like 3 4 days straight how long
are you here for only for like 3 4 days
oh so the whole time you're here I'm eat
nonstop bro literally I'm going try and
like put on a few pounds you know what
I'm saying was it like Robert dairo and
was it raging ball damn little reference
what about Robert J and Cape Fear all
prisoned out and shredded that's going
to be me when I get back to the UK bro
back on the UK food I'm about to lose
all the weight oh last random American
English question because you know we're
[__] dumb but how old are you I'm 30
30 maybe not one of my favorite shows
ever I ask everybody I only have like
five homies from the UK and I I hound
them the first time I talked to him the
show Absolutely Fabulous do you know
what I'm talking about one of my
favorite shows ever that's not what I
was expecting you to say one of my
favorite shows of all time I love that
show so much since I was a child I've
been watching it and where have you
watched that in America
I have it you have like and it's on it's
on Netflix now D the whole series on
netf and the movies I never been asked
by an American about ab ab that's crazy
oh so F so you you know what it is
that's what the nickname is all right I
grew up on that [__] that's like what my
mom used to watch and [__] when I was a
kid yeah yeah she used to love that I
used to see a few episodes every single
one of actually I thought you was going
to say like the British office or like
that [__] peep show or something I'm
sorry but I don't like that show The
Office America is the only office for me
I tried to watch went oh so Bland office
sick Bland office it's like it's like
our food our office is like our yeah
like it works you're going to laugh
Shameless kind of like that too yeah
there is a UK get the dirty grmy [__]
over here you know what I feel though I
know Americans don't rock with the UK
office like that but I feel is it's like
the
perfect example of like how British
humor is different to the US humor like
The the cringe embarrassing like
socially awkward UK like that is how
British people feel and express
themselves and then like you know the
way you guys got like Michael Scott and
it's kind of like goofy I feel it's just
like the perfect example of the
difference between us and UK humor 100%
you have one kid that's normal one ADHD
kid and we're America over here and then
you got what's what's what's the what's
the Russ uh Ricky jaase yeah yeah that's
him you know Michael Scott he's the more
sophisticated I'll make you laugh at a
nice restaurant and then Michael Scott's
at Burger King losing his mind I get it
you guys are smarter than us that's
really all it is think cuz I love
America and I I've always seen myself as
kind of like a honorary American cuz I I
think British people think they're
smarter than Americans but I feel like
Americans are smarter but not book smart
but like maybe not street smart but just
like in getting [__] done just like
Americans are like so dumb they're smart
I feel you got that thing where you just
like you just you just throw yourself at
life and just make [__] happen whereas
English people we think we're so smart
but we're so reserved like we think
we're smarter than the program you know
what I'm trying to say okay like English
people I feel like think they're so
smart that they don't got to do anything
and then like Miss opportunity if that
makes sense a no I agree I don't know
anything I agree with the American side
at least for me I just I just last I
always talk about the UK thing because
when I was a kid I'm I'm an American
like when I was a kid like America hell
yeah when I F as a kid when I found Tom
Jones was not American he was English
I'm like are you kidding me Le Zeppelin
don't talk like that and I heard Robert
Plant I'm like
what [__] and then Christian Bale was
like I'll be Batman and then he put his
regular a I'm like what is happening to
our country where we're not cool anymore
that sad CRA than about Terminator nah
let's get this full from Austria like
[__] son's Anarchy gangster dude yeah
all of our Classics are just like oh
they're not us sick but you know what's
funny I feel like British people have
done really well at infiltrating America
with acting singing Everything but never
rapping you guys do not rock with our
rappers bro you can't understand what
they're saying never works didn't I just
show you you just did this before you
got here randomly I I've been I've been
hearing some uh I met up with this dude
um he's a UK rapper he h apparently he's
famous as [__] I don't know he's just
getting some weed a long time ago storm
St storm Z storm Z yeah he's huge bro
he's one of the one of the goats in the
UK that's what they told me I was like
all right I don't know what the [__]
he's saying I can't understand this
person so I know that and I know um that
Central sea kid he's really really
popping that's the guy I just showed you
that made me was sick I I said like you
don't realize how different the
languages are to you hear the same
language you got to really slow down and
try to really like listen what the [__]
they're saying it's those FS the T the
th for the F but you know what really
bugs me out is like you guys just you
throw on some UK rap you guys can't
understand it but you throw on Ed
Sheeran and you guys picking up every
word that's the weird thing Ed shiran
can break through I I was just talking
about him the other day I I don't I song
play who is that like that's the red guy
he sings like that that I had no idea
he's the goat man he's like he's English
yeah yeah British guy yeah yeah that's
the crazy thing is like he's probably
been the mo one probably the most
successful British Artist of like the
last 5 10 years South and like he look
like a southern dude really I didn't I
don't I don't really listen to
uh mainstream music I guess you would
say so Ed Sharon he's like a singer I
just recently found out who the [__]
guy was recently and I just found out
Taylor Swift was famous 6 months ago so
that kind of puts you in like where I'm
at in perspective yeah is a funny one
cuz like in the UK he's got a lot of
clout in the rap scene cuz he's done a
couple of these like little albums where
he'll do a little five trck album and
he'll have a rapper on each track and
kind of like blow up some of the UK guys
so he's kind of really beloved in the
rap scene in the UK like he's it's the
sort of artist you would think like oh
he's mainstream people don't rock with
him but like people love Edge shum bro
like the most Street gangster like gang
affiliated rappers in the UK will be
rocking hanging out with Ed I saw Ed
sharan and Kodak Black hanging out and I
was like why what happen right there's
this rapper in the UK called Quang face
I mean you wouldn't have heard of him
but he's like from pekam which is like
very dangerous serious area of London
like he's doing like five years in jail
now but like there was just some crazy
there was just some random day where
like Ed shiron was just like in the Trap
with Quang face like super dangerous
rapper that you would never think Ed
shiran would be hanging out with and
they're just like chilling in like the
Bando it's just like Ed is certified
everywhere I thought it was Photoshop
when I saw him would call that but I'm
like why who thought of this did you
ever see Michael Jackson with the Crips
that throwing up the
yeah he was throwing up the sea for
children though I
think that was a deep deep love multiple
genre Burn Right There Fu you smoke I do
yeah do you want to smoke or you good
I'll smoke a little something I want to
make sure the conversation's still at
high level I'm just going to bust these
out for a minute I I got to say so in
the UK like the weed game is very basic
it's like primitive compared to what you
guys have got like we got medical
cannabis it's very early stage and
there's not much available so you guys
are like the scientists you got all the
next level stuff so you tell me about
what you guys got man everything you
think of this is just from our one of
our sponsors is ztics haven't tried
these yet these last crazy these are
brand new brand new haven't tried these
ones yet so we will see let's see this
is all fully legal right I'm not not
breaking no local laws I don't want to
be seen on camera doing anything illegal
no no no grab those pounds right there
no I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding bro I was ready I was let's go
it's funny I was going to bring a bunch
of them just for TC take some pictures I
was like I don't feel like carrying that
right right now just for the that would
be a cool set piece Bunch pounds what
are they call those uh bean bags like
bean bag pounds in the corner pound what
what does like a pound cuz I see rappers
hold in the big bag the pound and stuff
but like what does a pound cost I don't
even know like that's a whole another
level to me what year five years ago
before like it crashed a pound could
be youtubeers speaking in UK 18 or
thousand no 1,00 or 4K okay but now it's
like the super super super fires are
1100 bucks right now because like it's
it's crashed but some there's still a
couple strains out there for 10kp like
10K right across the board no breaks no
nothing there's stuff for 9k for 8K it's
all the boutique it's like yo this is
Louis Vuitton or this is burberry all
right this is [__] Hurley yeah but we
got the goofy like federal law and the
different state laws yeah so his
company's kind of found a way to kind of
go 50 states with it now which is brand
W nice yeah thca what um this is
something I would always been curious
about cuz I do I've semi followed it
like I always understood it's like it's
legal nice one it's legal in the states
it's ferally illegal and like there was
a whole thing where it's like if you had
a dispensary you had to just deal in
cash or something for a bit like is that
all change now everything is it's like
this all the time yeah like you're in
trouble I didn't get in trouble for that
but yo you got in trouble that I didn't
get in trouble for that you pay taxes I
didn't pay those taxes it's such a great
area right now that everyone's just
imagine this there's a riot and
everyone's looting yeah and some people
aren't because they don't want to get in
trouble those are probably the legal
companies and everybody else is just
[__] looting it's it's a very weird
time in the weed it's never been like
this ever yeah it's I I've always been
fascinated just in it just mainly
because of its uh proximity to rap music
to be honest cuz like for me just I'm
obsessed with rap anything rap I'm
interested in like even as a kid like
before I really knew what was going on
because I've been listening to rap since
I was like five six years old I just
always was curious like what is this
weed thing that all these rappers are
always smoking and [__] so it's like but
I like weed but I would say that like
I'm not necessarily the biggest
connoisseur like I kind of just quite
happy smoking mid and just I don't
really I don't even know what I got but
like is weed and music combined are you
like K back smoke and like that thousand
on the music that's how it is for me
yeah for sure watching watching stuff I
mean the funny thing with me is it's
like I I work a lot like I'm a bit of a
workaholic like to make like a
three-hour documentary on someone like
that is just weeks of me sat there just
watching loads of interviews listen to
albums making notes like for me I find
it's actually quite productive if I if I
smoke I usually I Vape but like Vape sit
lock in and watch like you know a few
three four hours of rap interviews and
like work and like make notes and like
analyze what's going on I just find like
the weed really helps with that
personally of course like thousand Focus
so you're born where
at we should show that I was born in a
place called Cen which is like just
south of London basically there's always
like this big debate on like is croin
actually London or not a lot of people
say it isn't like it's technically in s
but it's also it's like it's it's close
to London it's got the it's culturally
it's basically London I mean it's kind
of it's kind of known as like a bit of a
rough area sort south of London there's
like a lot of gangs and stuff but I was
born there uh I moved on I was about
five or six to a place called Bogner
Regis which you'd have never heard of
but it's basically like a very small po
poor Seaside town like at the south of
England and basically it's the place
where like I'll keep it real it's not
very diverse like you wouldn't growing
up I didn't see many black people
basically but I had older brothers that
kind of grew up more London and I was
just super into hip-hop so like I was
just obsessed with music and Hip-Hop and
Eminem and Jay-Z and 50 Cent when I was
a kid like my parents used to like not
want me listening to the stuff so they
would like you know hide my CDs and
stuff like that and I would just be like
secretly listening to the Jay-Z the
blueprint and stuff like that um but I
was living in this very boring poor like
nothing ever going on no rap music no
shows no nothing kind of place um and
then when I was 18 I moved back to
London to go to university and just kind
of like reconnected with hip-hop started
going to hip-hop shows like filming
music videos for local rappers like
getting back into this stuff that I
loved um and then yeah eventually man I
was doing rap videos and I was doing
stand-up comedy for a little bit yeah I
saw I saw a piece of there yeah yeah
yeah I was doing standup just for a
little bit like the standup comedy
circuit in London's kind of lit so it's
like what got you into that I just
always love comedy I mean I used to love
like my main things I was into was like
comedy and rap music so growing up I'd
be like listening to Eminem listening to
50 Cent watching Ricky ja watching the
office uh people like Jimmy Carr just
stand-ups that I love and so I I kind of
got into standup um I always wanted to
be a rapper as well though like I used
to rap I used to make little music
videos and do stand I was just kind of
being creative doing all this stuff um
and then eventually YouTube kind of took
off for me and I just was able to go all
in on that but like it was a very up and
down sort of roundabout journey to get
there did you do stand up as an in for
an income no I never got paid to do
standup just trying to do it because you
like it yeah I kind of like I had a few
friends that were like really active
some of them still going like really
active UK stand-up comedians like a good
friend of mine's guy called Ali Woods
who's like really blown up a lot this
year on social media doing standup he
was like a friend of mine in the circuit
and we would go and do open mics
together and stuff like that just going
I was just watch a lot of Comedy like go
to open mics like it was just a fun
little scene to be in but also I I felt
like it's like you really have to um you
really have to grind to get anywhere
with it like a lot of people they'll say
like if you want to make it stand up in
the UK you basically got to be
comfortable making no money for like 10
years I'll keep it real I wasn't trying
to make no money for 10 years so I kind
of was like really on the YouTube thing
so I was doing like stand up and sketch
comedy on YouTube like I was trying to
do the Andrew Schultz thing back in the
day doing like stand up and putting it
on my channel and stuff but it didn't
really pop like I did a few like comedy
sketches and like me and my homies that
did standup would do like sketch comedy
on YouTube together but eventually it
was the hip-hop stuff like the hip-hop
stories and the history that kind of
took off but I try I feel like I tried
everything man to try and get get on on
YouTube like I did it I started doing
YouTube in 2015 I was doing like
reaction videos sketches and literally I
grinded for like 4 years didn't get
anywhere I had like 200 Subs after four
years [__] didn't go anywhere and then
my homie basically said to me he's like
you love hip hop you love all this stuff
why don't you do some hip-hop videos and
I said to him I was like bro no one
wants to hear a white guy from Bogner
talking about hip-hop and he was like
just give it a go and like turns out
they did and like it just took off bro
as soon as I started doing the hip-hop
history I think people could really see
my enthusiasm and my knowledge for the
topic and then I think that is what
caused it to blow up because it was like
people looked at me and they'd be like
bro this guy don't know [__] about
hip-hop and then I start speaking and
they're like oh actually like kind of
does and I feel like that's always been
like my USP cuz it's like I'm not the
typical you know I'm not the typical
person you would look at and be like
this guy knows a lot about rap but then
I actually do I actually stand on the
knowledge and the topics that I talk
about so yeah it's been it's been a
blessing man I'm like grateful to have
gotten to this point so that transition
was purely out of a friend going hey won
you just try it yeah man it's my friend
ordinary things he's another YouTuber
who's who's really popping and uh yeah
you know it was kind of like we were
both just experimenting with YouTube
trying to make it work like he did um he
was doing like like movie Not reviews
but like movie analysis like uh video
essay type things and then he was like I
want to do more comedy with like history
on YouTube so he switched it up started
doing videos on like all sorts of
different just like random history of
interesting things like he just did a
big video on Like Satellites and like
SpaceX and stuff like that just like
interesting stuff with kind of jokes and
sketches and stuff but yeah he
encouraged me he was like do do some
hip-hop stories like if you see any of
my old stuff I'm trying to do more of
the comedy like I'm kind of roasting
rappers and like doing little skits and
stuff like I did a video where um what
did I do I used to do like fake
commercials for rappers like I did like
a a fake the baby Walmart commercial
because you know he shot a guy in
Walmart so I did like a Walmart
commercial featuring the baby and like
put a bunch of like footage of the baby
with a bunch of like Walmart music and
[__] like that or like I did a I did
like a commercial like you know Drake
with the whole thing when push a t
exposed him for having this baby with
the porn star um I did like a fake
commercial for like Drake bought this
really expensive watch that has I don't
if you ever seen this Drake basically
bought this watch for like 750k it's
like an erotic Richard Mill that's got
like sex sexy [__] on the watch so I
made like a fake commercial that was
like Drake's watch for like him knock up
this porn star basically so I was doing
a lot more like funny comedy hip-hop
skits like back in the day um and that
stuff just slowly took off man but like
as time's gone on as I've got into more
like the gangster the drill breakdowns
I've started to take things a lot more
seriously I don't really make jokes or
make light of these situations anymore
unless I'm doing something that's like
you know a little bit more of like a
gossip kind of thing like I think a lot
of people think that I just cover like
gangster stuff but I still do a lot of
like celebrity like I did the Eminem and
Kim kind kind a whole breakdown of their
marriage and how that affected M's
career even like the Kim and Kanye like
marriage and divorce did like a long
video on like their sort of rise and
fall and the breakup so like I cover a
lot of different things but it's like
it's the gang stuff and the drill stuff
that obviously like right now ganger rap
and drill it's just like everyone's
trying to learn about it and like I've
kind of become the guy for that stuff
which which is wild not in the damn
country you know what I'm saying right
like right now the best weed i' I've got
is from a guy from London
out here UK he moved over here he's been
growing for years damn just John's homie
it's like this is the best weed in
California you're not even from here
this is insane to me I mean it doesn't
matter where you're from just so wild
that such an American culture California
culture thing is like you're from where
[__] and like yo this drill music is C
who's who's covering it where are you
from it's just it's such an awe like you
said you don't expect it at the very
beginning I think it helps me like it's
funny when when I started I kind of felt
like I was like ah this ain't going to
work like no one's going to want a
British guy talking about this stuff and
it just so happens it's kind of like a
lot of people say to me it's like yo
you're like the BBC for like drill music
and [__] like that and it's like now in
hindsight it's like actually it makes so
much sense because like drill music if
you're not it's going to sound dumb the
way I'm saying this but like if you're
not from the streets or if you're not
familiar with I guess drill culture or
like rap music culture it's really hard
for you to understand what's going on
like if you throw on King Von album
you're not really going to understand
what's really being said so it's like I
feel like people that are new to the
genre or people that want to discover
these artists like they kind of need
someone like me to break it down in very
plain English and be like 100% this is
the area that these people you know
vanau is from or like these drill
rappers are from or whatever and then
like you know this is the music like
this is what we're talking about in the
music like this is how it affects
actually the history and the real life
of what's gone on and I think like I
really hope like some of the best
comments I get are when people say like
oh I never listened to this artist or
vaugh or Durk before but I watched your
video and I kind of got what it was all
about and now I love their music like
converting people to fans of the rappers
that I'm fans of like that gives me a
lot fulfillment I love that learning the
story before you hear the music's
totally different yeah because I think
in a lot of ways like
sometimes it's like you need to know
even just a little backstory to really
appreciate what's going on in the music
100% I I hear like say they sad but you
hear a rapper getting killed you don't
know who it is you look it up go this
F's music's tight D how's not more
popular and then they get they blow the
[__] up but 3 months ago if I watched a
video that you did about like oh this
B's been doing this for this long oh
[__] he's going to blow and that's how
you when a superstar pops they like
since when never ever heard of the guy
little do you know he's got 12 gold you
know mixtapes or two videos you've done
on him [__] like that because I told
Marty all the time I don't know a lot
about the a lot about newer music I'm
very I know what I like and that's it if
it's I don't I mean gangster music is
dope and [__] but a lot of the [__] now
is more of like yo I robbed this guy I
said his real name then he put us diss
track up these diss tracks are now like
premeditated murder tracks they're not
dis tracks anymore they're evidence
they're evidence they're proof like you
said you were going to shoot him on the
12th he got killed on the TW like I mean
Young Thug is in jail right now over
this [__] dude so I feel like a lot of
the music now I'm more like this is so
evil [__] you know what I think
something really interesting's happened
and I I don't really hear anyone else
talking about it whereas like I
feel True Crime content got really
popular in the last few years especially
on YouTube like the murder videos the
sort of like police interrogation videos
and I think that actually like there's
something really weird that's happened
recently where it's like you've got
these drill rappers that are really
doing the crimes they're talking about
and I think you're getting people that
are like True Crime fans attracted to
drill music CU it's kind of like it's
gangster rap meets real life true crime
stories and I think that it's like it's
really supercharged this this space and
drill music and in a way it's sad cuz
obviously Behind the Music there's a lot
of sad stories and people losing their
lives and people getting robbed and hurt
which I don't condone but at the same
time like the music's happening it's out
there we can't ignore it and pretend
it's not happening so we should be able
to like analyze it and understand it
even like the thug thing is interesting
cuz it's kind of like I did a thug sort
of a YSL sort of Gang video like a few
months before that indictment dropped
and like a lot of people like oh you
know you it's your fault like you snitch
but like bro these indictments that
takes years they've been they've been
looking at Thug but um you found the
[__] it's on the internet that's exactly
it's already there it's on their own
it's on their own social media but like
now it's like these songs are getting
used and it's it's crazy really when you
look at it and you look at some of these
lyrics and Thug's talking about we shot
at his mom and now he no longer mentions
me and like moms will really get in shot
like that that was a real thing like
that lyric is actually something that
happened and it's kind of like you know
whether or not you think lyrics
shouldn't be used in court and in
testimony it's like those lyrics exist
we all heard what he said and we all can
look up like this shooting actually
happened and it's this it's sort of like
this has never really happened in rap
music before like there's been a lot of
different eras of gangster rap whether
you want to go all the way back to like
IC te and NWA or even up to like 50 Cent
but it was like 50 cents appeal was
always like yo 50 is real he really got
shot nine times and lived and like 50's
got that lyric it's thing with 50 it was
always an ambiguous he never really
named the names like he had that lyric
where he's like the guy that shot me he
got hit like I got hit but he a [__]
breathe but he didn't say he got hit at
9:00
p.m. Steve Smith and he lives at 654 you
know what I mean and nowaday it really
is like that of Like Rappers will be
talking about the actual Street whether
it's they're saying like [__] 63rd or
even in the UK there's a couple rappers
that are like they have to censor their
lyrics now but a lot of them will be
like yo I caught him on this street well
there's there's a rapper in the UK that
did like yeah I did a drill on my
birthday and it's like bro the fed's
going to look up your birthday and like
see the drill that went down like don't
say that like you know I mean I'm a big
advocate of like don't snitch on
yourself like if I had any advice for
rappers like I don't condone crimes but
if you are doing crimes keep that to
yourself honestly like come up with a
fake crime to rap about and the real
crime adjacent throw them off the throw
them off the scent you should rap about
a bunch of [__] that never happened 100%
like when I tell stories about moving
hell packs go I make up a fake City all
right that's the other side of the State
uh all right different year go that's so
strict on snitching but we're on here
just talking about [__] it's weird yo
Marty that is a great [__] point
nobody wants us but you're doing it to
yourself I mean that's like a blatantly
blaring obvious weird thing yeah there's
something kind of messed up cuz I get a
lot of hate when people are like yo
you're snitching and it's like bro I'm
reading like Von's lyrics and it's like
let's be real like it's unfortunate but
like these dudes often are selfing like
telling on themselves and admitting to
stuff that they've done like with Thug
it's like bro he shouldn't have gone on
the mic and talked about shooting at
someone's mom hug you're that big yeah
legit and I I feel like he got to the
point where he felt he was so big that
it they would never come back for him
and it just goes to show you I feel like
this particular case let's see how the
court trial goes but it's like it just
goes to show the the the feds or the
state whatever you want to call it like
there's no time limit and the bigger you
are and the more famous you are the more
of a trophy you are to the feds exactly
a trophy is exactly cuz when you're a
cop and you're a little [__] and you're
trying to take down these fools you want
that guy every movie they take down the
mafia guy the cop goes I finally got you
and what happens he goes home and
nothing nothing changed so that's like
his biggest accomplishment of his life
you think they don't about I'm the guy
that took down Young Thug he loves that
as he plays his music like he loves that
[__] trophy what's up guys got a drop
off from Exotics I'm hyped you already
know zodic from many of our videos You'
seen on our social media zodic is a
premium cannabis company 100% white ash
Burns clean everything doesn't hurt my
throat everything is fire so right here
in abundance we have the grape guava
we've gone over it many times and here
we have the blue guava we've been
smoking this for weeks this is brand new
just got dropped off we just smoked that
[__] out of them this is the new
pre-rolls from zodic these called Next
Level rollup two pack Two Joints come in
here both 1.5 G so there's 3 G of rolled
up weed in this little box every strain
that they have everything they offer
they have a complete full breakdown on
zodic 420.com remember zodic is a legal
brand so you can go into stores and buy
this and for everyone out there that
doesn't feel like getting up and maybe
they want to get it delivered right now
you can go to droc california.com that
is 100% legal is a site for delivery
service that will deliver anything you
see that zodic carries or makes they
have it on that website they can be
delivered to you Dr california.com just
use our code Yola I'm going to finish
this joint let's get back to this
episode thank you so much have a dope
ass
day
damn I me this
[Laughter]
roach hey what's up guys guys we just
want to take a moment to talk about one
of our sponsors this is [__] you've
seen them on our Instagram you've seen
them on my story my Snapchat my Twitter
you've seen us smoking these you see
Marty eating the [__] out of the Edibles
go to their Instagram that's bash b o r
e d h a s h that's [__] they have a
telegram they're a licensed company this
is not a trapping it out kind of place
but if you want to check out for
information where they're carried where
you can buy remember go to their
Instagram they have their links there
[__] is 100% M from live resin fresh
frozen for everyone out there that it
likes vaporizers that likes pens that
likes carts this is something for you on
the Market this one right here is GMO
here's Gary pton this this is Lemon
Cherry gelato over here we got wedding
cake it's endless go ahead and check out
their Instagram that's board hash
everyone that wants to check out where
they're available and how you can get
them and remember guys this is a brand
new company coming to the W Market my
friend my personal homie manufactures
and produces everything for this brand
if you smoke live resin pens maybe try
board hatch you might fall in love with
it like this guy over here is smoking 12
a day so guys remember [__] on
Instagram go ahead and check him out
leave a comment drop a like drop a
follow support supp the brands that
support us thank you so much back to the
episode are you getting ever like inside
sources or is it basically all just info
that you find off the internet that
you're using for your research I I've
always made a conscious effort to just
stick with the online research like I've
always felt like my skill like my
superpower is like I'm very very good
when it comes to like finding hidden
info like I know all sorts of techniques
of like using Google in a way where you
can find stuff that maybe isn't always
going to come up on the the normal
search or like things like Twitter
advanced search like finding tweets that
are like hi or deleted tweets or like
tweets if you got somebody that's just
tweeted millions of tweets like
narrowing down and finding tweets that
are relevant stuff like that so I
personally have always taken the opinion
of like I don't really want to get
inside sources cuz I'm not I'm genuinely
not a snitch like I'm not trying to
expose people I'm not trying to get
inside info from like someone's baby
moms who is going to expose somebody
like my the whole point of my videos is
they're meant to be like a perfect
collection of just all the info that's
out there about to three four hour at a
time
break like true like Storyteller would
like we're going to analyze everything
here and just lay it all out at once and
it's easy to follow that's that's why I
like it that's really what I aim for is
like I really want to help people
understand just like everything there is
to know on a topic and it's not
necessarily about like trying to
sensationalize it or anything like that
but it's like I just want to tell the
story in a way that you're going to
remember it and that you're going to
actually understand and appreciate like
what was really going on in a certain
situation and like
you know the videos have just gotten
longer and longer and I I've tried to
like push myself and be more ambitious
about like the ideas I take on like
doing like the six hour young boy video
it's like I hour 6 hour I did on young
boy yeah but it's like I felt like I was
looking into young boy and I was like
bro this guy's life and his story is so
complicated no one's Everly ever
properly broken it down I feel like
young boy is such a misunderstood artist
that I was like bro I'm just going to I
didn't say I'm going to do a six- hour
video but I just said like I'm going to
tell the whole story I'm going to tell
like every beef every album like I want
to tell the story behind every album I
want to tell like when cuz the guy
releases loads of music like I think a
lot of people think like young boy oh he
just shits out music and don't he just
floods the market with music and don't
really think about it but like the guy's
stuck at home on house arrest for like
years and years he's got nothing to do
but record like every album is kind of
telling a different story about where he
is in his life at that that moment and
it's like no one ever really broke that
down so it happened to take me 6 hours
to break it all down but this guy's got
dozens of albums and I was like I want
to leave no stone unturned I want to
tell every beef every album every
relationship every child every murder
that took place like just everything
about this guy's career and I want it
all in one video like I don't want to be
I don't like splitting videos up and do
a part one I just want to do like yo if
you ever wanted to know anything about
young boys in this video ain't nothing
we missed really sums up it's like the
tale of the tape from UFC like this is
exactly everything you need to know
about the guy go listen to his music
yeah and that's the thing bro it's like
I'm a huge fan like all of the artists
that I cover like I couldn't sit there
for like a month or two months just
researching one artist if I didn't love
them and love their music like bro I'm a
super fan like all the artists I cover
all the stories and situations like I'm
fanatic about them like I love young boy
music I love Von's music like I love
Little D's music I'm obsessed so like
any way that I can like help people
enjoy the music like I'm hyped like
that's a huge positive for me so what's
the overall feedback band from the world
oh man I got to be honest man you know I
really appreciate the love that I get
about the videos because like people do
really appreciate the effort that goes
in and they do really see it like I I
never feel like I drop a video and feel
underappreciated like I always see hella
comments of people are just like yo you
really went over and above and like
you're you're making content in a way
that no one no one else does or no one
else has and like that's what I'm trying
to do like when I tackle a project like
I'm trying to say like cuz there's a
couple videos about young boy that are a
couple hours long and I'm looking at
them and I'm like I got to do something
different I got to do something bigger
and better and you know I'm blessed that
like people do really appreciate that
and they the effort put into videos like
people do see and they appreciate it and
and they they [__] with it um you know I
do get hate people sound a snitch or
like they say that I'm racist or
whatever you know I just I find stuff
like that wild cuz it's just people like
you're racist and it's just like bro all
I do is like listen to Black music every
day celebrate black artists like put
money into the black economy like I I
love Black Culture whether it's like
when I was growing up doing comedy like
I used to look up to people like Dave
Chappelle Eddie Murphy like Chris Tucker
I used to watch DEATH Comedy Jam when I
was like I was like under 10 years old
Watching Death Comedy Jam just like I
love this [__] so it's like when people
say like I'm racist and stuff I just
find it it's just super dumb but like
people do you know people do hate and it
is what it is but it's a surface level
reaction to just white people are
talking about of course of one other
question there are many ignorant people
out there have you gotten any backlash
that is real life not just yo I don't
like you are you getting backlash from
these because you aren't putting out
anything that that isn't already out
there that people have spoke themselves
wrote down and got paid for like this is
in the lyrics man these are interviews
that they went and took their time and
showed up and did yo all right ready to
start yeah so this is what I did once
it's not like your DJ Vlad and you're
like yo tell me about this time I mean I
know he's not blatantly trying to do
that but if there's anybody that's ever
gotten some [__] out of somebody like yo
cut that there's also a whole genre that
like on YouTube now of people like
policing Comedians and podcasters too
and like but they are also talking [__]
making fun of them in their own way at
the same time too so like that whole
Lane is like a thing now too you know
where it's like not the same thing it's
slightly adjacent or you got you ever
watch coffeezilla we were just talking
about him like a detective I'm anybody
who's out here scamming I'm going to
investigate the [__] out of you and
bring it to light in the best way
possible yeah I do get that kind of
thing but at the same time I've never
had I've never had that kind of hate
really in real life like I mean I did
live show is my first live show with DJ
academics and C in London like last week
and I was just overwhelmed by the amount
of love and positivity I got in person
like I met hella fans it was just all
love I know it's like I was on the event
so it's going to be love but it's like
I'd not really got like I fans come up
to me and take piic on me every now and
then and like you know it's cool but
I've never really had anyone hate on me
like that in person no I don't mean in
person like online like yo if you show
up over here it's going to be bad if you
come to San Francisco or if you're in
Texas or I get that [__] yeah I do get
that the the but you know what's funny
is it's like I mean one of the worst
ones I had like before V died like I
made a couple videos about him when he
was alive and like he tried to take my
channel down and like they were doing
fake copyright strikes and stuff on me
and like eventually they I basically got
pressed by his team on the phone and I
to like take one of my videos I did
about him down but like at the same time
you know I get stuff that people like yo
don't come to Chicago but I get a lot of
love from other people who are actually
like people that really people you would
know in Chicago and they're like no
you're good over here like you should
come and I I do want to go to Chicago I
don't really think it's that serious I'm
a YouTuber I think it's like people like
to jump in comments and act tough and
act hard like they're going to do
something but like really like who's
like who's really going to slide on a
YouTuber that's reading court papers
like come on like I'm not really
involved I've not really had any impact
or influence on the situations like I
ain't never hurt anyone or killed anyone
like I'm just reading about famous cases
and that's the thing that bugs me as
well sometimes people are like yo I get
DMS and they're like you shouldn't be
talking about these rappers and
gangsters in Chicago I'm like bro these
are billboard charting artists bro like
Lil Dirk he'll go top five on Billboard
when he drops a song talking about we're
sliding and getting back for this person
or that person and it's like bro if if
you're putting a song out that's on the
Billboard charts you like you can't be
surprised that that there's journalists
and people out there talking about
literally like it's like these are this
is what I think it's like if you made
something that's so famous it's on
Wikipedia you can't be mad that I'm
talking about it cuz like these these
situations they're getting written about
In Articles like Chicago Tribune LA
Times talking about these situations I
mean even like I did the Draco the ruler
story and it's like there's so many
articles about him and the situations he
was in and his court case and it's like
this stuff is so out there all I'm doing
is I'm good at putting it together and
making more people get interested in it
but I think that means like the people
that want to hate or the people that
feel some type of way it's like they got
someone that's like easy Target and then
it's like oh and he's he's white and he
looks like a nerd and he's he's Goofy
and we can press him and he's not going
to do anything and it's like there's
just not really many points to be gained
from like pressing me and like saying
that I'm a bad guy for like making
documentaries like I'm not really
involved I'm just talking about stuff
that's famous already you have a lot of
rappers as well like they'll post some
stuff and then they'll be mad that
people aren't giving it promo so it's
like yo like you know I just brought a
million people like even um when I I did
a live stream with 100K track who was
King Von's manager and he was saying um
he was like bro he said I'm not going to
lie to you like after that Von
documentary dropped a lot of people were
hating but Von's streaming number
numbers went up like they made a bag off
of me getting everyone talking about V
out of nowhere and then like his
postumus album came out a couple months
later now I'm not saying like I'm
responsible for their success but like I
probably added a few you know saying a
few little few numbers to their streams
and like didn't hurt that that's making
you money like you know what I'm saying
I'm literally helping you and that's
free and it's not you're like I think
he's a bad guy I think he's a piece of
[__] also this is who he killed you're
not I've watched your videos you're not
being biased I mean I mean you're
unbiased I try to be you know I try and
take a very objective view like
sometimes I have said like you know
there there's a situation one of one of
my stories where you've got a guy that
like shot up a car and it had like a
woman and a child in it and I kind of be
you know I kind of be saying like yo
that's that's not cool like that's
really bad behavior and [__] like that
um but like overall like I'm not really
here to pass judgment on like often
actually I'm very sympathetic and people
hate on me for this too as I'll say like
even in the Von video a lot of people
like oh you made King Von look like such
a bad guy and it's like well bro he
called himself self a demon and like
he's rapping about catching bodies but
even then at the start of the
documentary I have a whole sequence
where I basically say yo look like Von
is a guy he grew up in one of the most
dangerous environments in America you
know in the south side of Chicago in
public housing like he was growing up in
a difficult environment he saw his
father get murdered like this guy became
a demon but he went through so much [__]
you got to have some sympathy and then
you know I talk about the guys that
killed FBG Duck and I kind of say like
look it's bad what they did but you got
to remember that like these guys were
born into this situation where you're
growing up you're losing your friends
your friends are getting killed you're
involved in this gang war at age 12 13
you don't even really know what's going
on so like I still have sympathy because
I feel like everybody involved whether
you lose your life or you do life in
jail like you didn't really choose to be
put in that situation and you know I I
know that I have privilege and and like
I'm not from the hood like I grew up in
a poor boring Seaside town and like I've
not had to go through what like someone
like V went through so I do have
sympathy I'm try and put that in the
videos but not everyone picks up on that
cuz you can't understand unless you've
seen that happen to a kid before yeah
witness the kid's brain wiring change to
the point that they are completely a
different human than they would have
been had they not gone through all that
[__] you know it's that's the thing I
think some people they like to be like
oh you know these gangsters they're just
out of control and like you need to just
lock them up we need to be hard on them
and like you know I see where that's
coming from but then also on the other
hand it's like I personally think like
the real reason for a lot of like gang
violence and stuff like that is like
economics like we're talking about areas
that like there's no funding there's no
investment in like areas like you talk
about oock like all these gangsters and
gangs that have emerged out of oock but
then it's like yo the city of Chicago
has never looked after the people in
oock like you got to ask yourself like
what what are the situations and
circumstances that exist that have
allowed people to become these hardened
gangsters and killers and feel like they
have to sell drugs to survive CU there's
no opportunities in these areas and it's
like I really do try and put myself in
the shoes of like the the say the rapper
I'm talking about or if I'm talking
about you know a gang situation like the
guys that have got themselves caught up
in gangs cuz it's like I never lived
that so I need to try and like at least
mentally like put myself in those shoes
and understand because it's very easy to
pass judgment when you don't know what
that's like and like I ain't been there
so I'm I'm at least trying to to just
like mentally put myself in that
position one thing that I feel like
could help really the American inner
city as a whole is if we just stopped
hitting kids as parents overall stops
hitting kids yeah holy [__] me a hot
take when you grow up and you're over
there and you see how bad kids get hit
normally by their parents that will
change a kid forever if you can't trust
your parents not to hurt you the average
person goes on their whole childhood
when they go off into the world at 13
they have no problem hurting anybody cuz
they've beat by your parents all life I
get I get that but getting slapped in my
[__] mouth by my mom taught me not to
be [__] Fu rude in person there's
levels to it there's levels yeah I'm not
getting my ass stomped out go sit in the
dryer cuz he's bad no that's crazy
blasting your kid that's insane like
really like that type of [__] is thought
you like shut up no I like what do you
mean hit your kid have a kid I me when I
was over there all the time man that was
just normal like the the problem with
that it teaches a kid I don't have kids
yet but like it teaches a kid that like
violence is the answer and then you know
you can't be surprised if that kid grows
up and then uses violence on someone
else
like there's there's other I guess I
don't have a kid but it's like I'm sure
there's other ways to discipline a kid
you know violence like that's if
anything like last resort or just not at
all but I think that's a super good
point because it's like again it's one
of the sad situations I see a lot with
like these young guys that gangster
rappers that get fall in with gangs and
you know unfortunately in a lot of them
it's like their father's been killed or
aren't around and then it's like they're
not really learning how to operate how
to react whether it's getting hit and
learning that violence is the answer or
just like seeing you know lots of people
around you lose their lives and death
just become like meaningless to you you
know to me it's like I've had people
pass away in my life but it's like you
know I've not been in a situation where
like five of my friends from school have
been shot and killed and like that must
change you and change the way you think
must change the way you think about life
like if you got to take a life and all
your friends have been killed or a bunch
of your friends have been killed like
taking a life probably ain't that much
of a stretch to you whereas me that
would be a big stretch like the idea of
even in self-defense killing somebody is
like it's it's it's completely foreign
out of my conception whereas like you
seen if you've seen people die on your
block like that's normal like it
probably ain't that much of a stretch
for you to pull the trigger on someone
or end up like them like I'll shoot you
first I've seen fools die and that going
to be me that's mainly the mindset I
think is what comes MH that's I mean
just from people I know like that's
that's what it is MH and I get it I I'm
not have to been there and shoot back at
fools like that like that's crazy when
you have kids you realize just how
crucial that like those couple years are
when you're a kid like how vulnerable
you are how sensitive you are how
impressionable you are you're getting
wired like a computer what direction is
it going to go in like if you never
experienced that you don't get it like
it seems so insane but it's like they
programm differently yeah yeah fully man
and you know I
mean I've never been a huge believer in
like rap music making people more
violent but at the same time I do think
like kids that are listening to drill
music have got to understand that like a
lot of these themes and things like they
need to understand that like if
somebody's jumping on the mic talking
about all these people they shot that's
not cool that's not starting to
glamorize like that person is talking
about those things because they've been
through a hard time and they got to
defend themselves because when Dr rap in
Chicago came out that [__] became
Buffalo new [__] the dreadlocks the
[__] switches all that became the
common in Buffalo too like people will
just think that shit's cool and it
really will affect the way the whole
[__] goes like yeah I mean it's
influenced the UK a lot cuz it's like
Chicago drill you know really blew up
like 2012 when Like Chief Keef really
had his Heyday um and then a lot of
people have come since but it's like
that was like that Golden Age like 2012
and it's like over the course of the few
years after that in like 2015 16 like UK
drill became a thing like we used to
have like gangster rap they used to call
it like Road RP but it was it was very
small you know it wouldn't do numbers
people didn't really have careers off
the back of road RP but like Chicago
influenced the UK so much that UK drill
emerged and now UK drill kind of has
found its own sound and then that's
influenced like Brooklyn drill and like
all the beats and [__] that you hear in
the Bronx or like when like pop smoke
was popping in like 2019 he was raing on
UK beats which like basically a re
remixing of like Chicago drill beats
with kind of like UK dance music Vibes
that's what it sounded like we we the
first time I heard was some [__] club
music he talking about shooting you in
the chest but this is club music I swear
the tempo it was like where the girls at
I guess that's the thing it's like like
some dance music almost so it's like the
UK producer they kind of took like the
dark not percussion like the dark Vibes
and and instruments that you would hear
on like a on a Chicago drill beat but
then they start to mix it with like a
lot faster like 140 BPM drums that you
more hear on like UK like dance music
like garage music or or dubstep kind of
things and like then rapping about gang
life over that and it became its whole
new thing and there's kind of a whole
story with like pop smoke he basically
just found a bunch of UK drill beats on
YouTube he didn't even know they were UK
beats so he started working with this
big like UK drill producer and like he
produced I think it's 808 mellow
produced like a lot of Pop smokes big
hits like Dior and stuff like that and
it's like got that UK sound and then pop
smoke kind of popularized that UK sound
like two I don't if you know 22gs but he
was doing kind of like those beats
probably before pop smoke but like pop
smoke really brought it mainstream and
then now the crazy thing that is now
it's like Bronx and Brooklyn drill type
beats have become so big it's like
mainstream like ice spice like Munch and
all the beats that she's rapping over
like those are UK drill type sounded
beats and it's so like even though you
guys don't really mess with any of our
rappers the Beats our beats you guys are
all over our beats bro I hear it
everywhere yeah yeah so it's UK like
that percussion style of like you know
when you hear popm smoke Dior and it's
like like the way that the kind of like
the claps are kind of staggered and like
the 808's really like hit it's just do a
video on this yeah yeah that's the thing
I've kind of mentioned it in a few other
things but it's like you sometimes it's
difficult to do a video that's not about
a person if that makes sense if you sort
of like the history of UK drill from
Chicago to UK it like don't really hit
as a title so you've almost got to like
pick an artist I could do I did do like
a mini pop smoke video but I think once
the trial of the guys that kill pop
smoke happens like I might do the full
pop smoke like life story and that would
be a good way to kind of talk about how
he popularized those beats but going
back with all this wild chick going on
with Will Smith yeah yeah could there be
a Will Smith video coming up breaks down
you know what man I I really want to
start doing maybe a couple videos that
are a little bit outside of hip hop not
that I'd want to like get out of the
hip-hop space or anything like that but
it's just like I do have other interests
like slightly Beyond hip-hop whether
it's like films like I I really want to
do a video breaking down the history of
this YouTuber boxing thing because it's
kind of like over the past five or six
years the whole YouTuber boxing thing
has become so big but there's been like
so many people that have been involved
in like building this scene and I'd love
to do like my style of video where it's
like get all the info all the stories
all in one video I'd love to do that on
like a few other topics like the
YouTuber boxing I mean Will Smith thing
is interesting obviously like there's
just so much to it like having listened
to his his I listened to the audio book
of his autobiography like I'd recommend
anybody watching this bro go and listen
to Will Smith's autobiography cuz he
reads it and he performs even like raps
he puts in like little RS in the
autobiography it's crazy it's actually
fire it's like 14 hours of will it's
crazy bro bro it's like some of the best
it's like the best 10s I ever spent bro
Will Smith autobiography is lit it's
crazy but yeah I'd recommend it what an
advertisement I love that I kind of want
to I don't got to read it I'll listen to
Will Smith talk I already watch fresh
prins bro in the car like I know what
traffic's like over here bro if you need
like if you're doing like a two three
hour drive bro throw that on like it's
it's fire and I never knew so much of
the history of Will Smith where he's
talking about like obviously he was a
rapper he won a Grammy as the fresh
prince and then he got the TV show The
Fresh Prince like in the book he's
talking about like he was a a house
party at Quincy Jones's house and
Quincy's like let's do an audition right
now for this new show I got that's the
fresh Prince and Will Smith's like what
you want me to audition now like we're
at house party and like uh Quincy Jones
is just like bro this is your moment do
it and like he did an audition on the
spot got the show became the Fresh
Prince like the guy Will Smith's life
story is like crazy bro he's like the
real Forest Gump or something bro he's
like been in every era just killing it
bro it's crazy first thing I thought was
like he can't run good I don't know why
that's the first thing I thought of was
the braces on the
legs so hold on Will Smith like yo his
dad be so he's like yo I'm a good actor
is my dad beat beat me so what you're
saying is when I have kids like every
Sunday just like you're going to college
right it's a little like face smush but
I love you but you're going to be
something yeah well you know what was
interesting from the book cuz Will's
talking about how he was kind of really
hard on his kids and he he basically
like he was basically saying he was like
a normal Dad if your kid says they want
to become a singer you maybe get them
some singing lessons and encourage them
and he was like but me being Will Smith
I got Willow Willow in the studio and
got did whip her head back and forth and
made her a number one
selling artist at like 11 or however
young she was and he was talking about
how like he kind of had to realize he
had to check himself cuz he realized
like his daughter basically was like
Willow was like I'm kind of done with
the singing thing now I'm bored of this
and he was he was like no we got to do a
world tour we got to do this and that
and he was like I had to check myself
and realize like I was becoming this
pushy father but like even if my
daughter she did a hit song and she
don't want to do that [__] anymore he
was like I need to just listen to her
feelings and like not be so pushy and
like how Will's father was kind of he
wasn't pushing him to be an actor but he
was just like very hard on him and all
this kind of stuff and I don't know man
it just such an inspiring book but like
hear I think of a quote from wil's Dad
all the time if you want to build a
brick wall you don't build it in one day
you put a brick up every day eventually
you'll have Wall every time you've been
quoting that quote yeah that's where I
got it's from Will Smith's dad for three
years I've heard this quote from Marty
I've used it once cuz it worked really
well never did I know it was Will
Smith's father you are a
fool holy [__] Bro there's like a whole
chapter in the book about that wall man
him building that wall with his dad and
[__] like it's it had a huge impact on
him it's great metaphor man it's like
it's actually I remember I just started
the book and I was like what the [__] he
keeps talking about this wall bro he
keeps talking and talking about this
wall that he was building but like it's
like a perfect metaphor for his career
and bro it's crazy man like that book is
nuts I could I could sit here for hours
talking about that book bro so funny cuz
I built a fence with my dad but he was
on meth so like it wasn't the same for
me but then again it did make me work
hard like I don't ever want to build a
[__] Bob Ware frence again in my life
bro if Will Smith's dad had meth we
wouldn't have none of this no handc no
irot or what if we just had a more hyped
at version of all of these things if
Will Smith was on meth now that would be
a movie I'm trying to see would the
pursuit meth the pursuit of meth yo when
you come you should come hang out more
because these are the things that I love
to hear the pursuit of meth by Will
Smith by Will with his son and [__] but
that that's another crazy son being sold
yeah he needs drug money bro they
sleeping in that bathroom you know what
I'm saying me and he's like give me that
$5 get you back tomorrow like I don't
have $5 sir you you want a sexual favor
for some meth that's pretty much the end
of the movie Yo wil's getting hard right
now on the internet man he's going
through it right now there's a lot of
stuff coming out about him that's a good
puno J J Jada man J Jada did him dirty
man she did big fan of that lady she
seems very uh as second you leave the
room she turns back in you ever seen the
movie uh witches you probably I haven't
actually seen it no for the old one the
UK one no the the old English movie
about a that sounds like UK for sure
that sounds like J P Smith like she
turns into a witch and her wig comes off
yeah you seen the movie you know what
I'm talking about um sorry we're way way
way off you do so much you do you're a
virtual journalist out here you're
you're a journalist you're doing all of
these things about American rap UK rap
you touch on too from a person from
there what are your three three favorite
artists because you know none of the
people besides the eight homies from UK
that were on the chat know who we're
talking about so you Enlighten us what
you're an
expert not you said stormy right he's
like is what's his what's his equivalent
American thing with stormy stormy is a
bad example stormy is a Grime rapper so
here's the thing you got to understand
understand like there's Grime and then
there's UK drill and they're actually
very different like Grime in many ways
like inspired UK drill but Grime was
like the precursor so stormy is a Grime
artist he's not a drill artist what does
that mean Grime like the way that the
Beats like the kind of Beats they rap
over are very different do you know the
rapper skepta you heard of him yes so
like he was like one of the real
pioneers and like big names in Grime
it's hard to describe but like the grime
beats are a little bit more like they're
kind of kind of
more more closer to like dance music or
like kind of like I did not expect that
not not like dance music but like more
like what UK would be like kind of
garage dubstep kind of like got it's
hard to describe it like Grime beats
like the kind of sounds you would hear
in Grime beats it's like um I don't
trying to think like do the it's hard to
explain CU if you you can't explain that
and you're an expert it's like well how
do I explain the feeling if I played you
I don't want to we can't get copyrighted
but like if I played you the two
different beats like Grime beats it's
much more like so the beats are very
different they've just got a different
sound you would know if you heard the
difference in sound but then the the
subject matter like Grim's a bit more
about like mcing and like having battles
and clashes and stuff like that okay and
then UK drill the beats are different
they're much more darker and like the
percussions much more kind of harder but
then the the subject matter is all about
gangs violence like like Chicago drills
so it's kind of like so drill music is
gangster music it's basically like UK
gangster rap yeah that's that kind of
thing it's like Grime was much more
about like mcing and rappers and like
having bars and it was more about the
rapping whereas drill it's more about
the drilling and the violence and
talking about real [__] that happen
story yeah exactly so like storm is more
of a Grime artist like Storm's you know
he's like one of the greats in the UK so
what what's his comparison like if you
like yo he's the something of UK he's
the he's the this of UK like I'm talking
about in terms of popularity I would say
he's
like not quite Kendrick he's like so
he's top 10 he's yeah yeah yeah top five
I'd say top five top five ranked he's
like he's like nearly a I'm trying to
think who's like an artist that's like
seen as a good actual rapper with bars
with Integrity not quite at Kendrick's
level who's that guy
um man I can't remember the guy's
name nah I can't I can't remember but
like I see what you're saying but you're
saying his top five the [__]
can't walk down the street without
getting oh yeah stormed yeah a that's
what I'm trying to think like so he's
your you know people say he's the
Michael Jackson of China yeah that's
what I'm trying to get in the terms of
cuz we don't know any of this and we do
I just named two artists that I've heard
from UK and that's because i' they come
up on the Spotify and that's it no I
don't think Americans are going H UK
drill not a lot yeah it's a very very
it's like when anime was small in
America like you nerd you like what do
you want Dragon Ball Z when I was a kid
everybody made fun of that [__] I like
Dragon Ball Z I thought it was cool and
then now it's like anime is popular so
maybe give it five years you know CU
Central SE kid is collaborating with
some of the biggest artists in the world
s c is like up there I would say you
know as far as like the artists that
have the momentum and the motion right
now in the UK he's probably number one
realistically and he he's one of the
first people that Americans are really
excited about like I was in yeah I was
in Miami in January and like I people
were coming up to me being like yo like
Central sea like we [__] with him out
here and so he's really gone Global he's
collaborated with a lot of international
artists and gone big so he's definitely
up there man Central's one of them like
as far as other people who are really
big you would mention from the UK like
is a big one who's like really done like
had mainstream like chart success um
with drill music and like he's kind of
got you know history in the streets and
he he was part of this this sort of gang
crew called 1011 and they basically got
banned from making music by the police
so like he caught this crazy case and
they had this wild like shootout in
public broad daylight and [__] loads of
members got sent to jail and they got
banned from making music so Digger was
banned for music for a little bit he
eventually got out of jail and he's
super young as well um and then he got
out of jail started making music again
there was like a BBC documentary about
him about how he was kind of like banned
from making music and the police were
just trying so hard to put him back in
jail and eventually he kind of got his
music career back on track and I think
he's got a big deal but um you know he's
another person that's kind of doing it
big from the UK there's a lot of names
man it's it's hard to like single anyone
out or to do like a top three but
there's definitely a lot like other
people to check out like Hy one is kind
of like one of the greats when it comes
to UK drill kind of from like the street
side and like stories and stuff he was
kind of he very famously had this
situation where he kind of like got
caught lacking um and like he was
basically filmed like getting beaten up
and like chased out of this University
after his show and then there was this
whole thing where it was like the next
day there was like some crazy shooting
and people were like oh it's like the
get back for like what happened to him
and then he dropped this song kind of
about that situation called no better
that was just super viral it's one of
the hardest UK drill songs he kind of
popularized like doing like sh as adlibs
it's like he had this song that was
famous he was like next day sh got got
by sh and like he was like the first guy
to do that basically and so like he he's
gone on to become like one of the greats
and he's had like I can't remember I
think he had a number one album in the
UK and like he's collabed with a lot of
big American artists he did a track he's
one of the guys that did a song with
Drake so he did The Only You Freestyle
with Drake and that was like a huge
moment for the UK like getting the Drake
coign so yeah H's a really good one like
obviously like he has a big beef with
this other rapper called ton Wayne who's
like another one of the greats when it
comes to UK drill he's kind of a bit
more like on a party kind of wave like
he's his music like he had a number one
song in the UK with another rapper who's
dope from UK called Russ Millions so
like T on Russ Millions I think it was
the first UK drill number one song in
the UK so that was like a crazy moment
this track called body so it's ton Wayne
and Russ millions and that was nuts but
like in the UK it's now got to a point
it's only over the last few years when a
few of these really big artists have
come through that like we kind of on the
radio in the UK you we're more trying to
hear our own UK drill artists and
American artists now like Americans
still do well but like most of my life
American rappers have always been like
on the UK charts like 50 would drop a
song and it would go number one in the
UK or whatever but like now the UK
artist are getting way more respect when
it comes to rap so it's like growing up
all the kids that in school were
listening to American rappers I mean
like I said I grew up in this small town
so like no one really listened to rap I
was the odd one out no one was into it
but me what people listen to Pink Floyd
Beatles
like Indie like when I was a kid when I
was like a teenager and I was listening
to rap like all the people my age will
listen to like Indie so like [__] like
uh I know like Oasis or like yeah I know
but that [__] was 15 years before yeah
that that's what we were into or like uh
I don't like the killers oh yeah but we
got that [__] oh we're almost the same
age when you were in high school yeah so
you were on the same [__] oh but I I
didn't list I literally BR I do not
listen to anything other than rap music
bro people are like oh do you listen to
this this genre I'm like bro I do not
listen to other music that isn't rap
music I just can't like I think it's cuz
it's like I had older brothers so all I
ever heard was rap music like when I
hear songs that aren't rap and it's not
like 16 bars of rapping in a chorus like
I'm like bro what is this like I don't
like how this song is structured like
for me it's just always been rap music
so it's like I don't like you do have
some of the best rock music in the
world's history I wouldn't know bro I
ain't heard none of it wow I don't hear
any of that [__] bro just rap music
that's all I got and it's like it's
difficult cuz people oh you must have
heard this I'm like nah like the best I
can give you is I've heard like all the
Beatles And I think I get like the
songwriting is quite good or like Ed
Shan but that's it like wow it's all rap
for sure I always said damn UK's got
such better music than this [__] man
yeah you're that's crazy we're [__]
flip-flopped as a kid I'm like damn all
these UK guys are so cool why are they
have to be non-american and you're over
here listening to nothing but rap like
we we were flipped I feel like the UK
had a really I I'm not that into it but
it's like the UK has such a good run on
like rock music and [__] like throughout
the years like the Beatles and stuff
like like even some like yeah Adel even
like that kind of yeah yeah hella hella
people but like that's the funny thing
is like me growing up all I was trying
to hear was like Eminem Jay-Z 5 C Nas
like you're Marty you know what I'm
saying yeah he just cross the water a
little bit he's out there in New York
it's like that's for me like people
always say this to me like why were you
so into rap music and like I feel like
for me it was all about like success and
like just hearing these guys that come
from nothing or like come from people
like J come from the M projects and was
dealing drugs to becoming
multi-millionaire and like I was a kid
watching all the music videos and
they're on like yachts and driving
Bentley and I just thought these were
the coolest people I'd ever [__] seen
in my life did you see his interview he
just did with Gail King or whatever I
haven't seen it yet I know the one
you're talking about well he said the
same thing he's like hip-hop was the
first time where it was like you could
become successful without going to
Harvard or going to some school but you
could actually be broke and have nothing
and have this like Bridge To Success
yeah made it possible uh that for me
that's what allured me to it most man
cuz I i' would see even like even the
the money for sure but even just like 50
Cent the idea that yo he got shot nine
times and survived like this guy's
Invincible like this guy's the real
Terminator and he come back and he sold
10 million albums and proved everyone
wrong like I just remember being a kid
hearing that story and like that music
video of in the club where like you know
you know the story you know 50 got shine
shot nine times and the start of that
music video where he like comes down
from the roof and he's like in the in
the uh the Doctor's lab with do
and I'm watching I'm like yo this guy
got shot nine times and like he is
jacked like he is yolked like pause but
like you know what I mean like he looks
amazing get a Vengeance like [__] I'm
alive I'm with Dre I was like I want to
be 50 like I want to be like this guy
like I want to embody what what this guy
this guy's energy and even and even like
Eminem like you know I I grew up and
like you know there was times when I was
like an Angry Kid and like you know what
I'm saying didn't get one with my
parents or they they didn't want me
listening to rap music or like whatever
and I just like you hit Eminem that's
just like all that anger kind of comes
out of you and the way he's expressing
it and the way he's so lyrical and he
can actually like like even you think a
song like Stan like he can paint a whole
picture and tell a whole story in three
verses and like have multiple characters
and like the song Stan is like a movie
yeah and I was just so inspired by rap
music man like I would listen to that
then someone might play like the Beatles
and i' be like this [__] bro this ain't
nothing on Emin like bro like Eminem is
like like it the songs were literally
like movies like you could see it like a
movie in your mind I was just so
inspired by this music the like it's
different energy yeah man for sure it's
a whole different energy you put into
rap music than you would do in like
completely you know what I mean like
days to confus like it's a whole rap
music is all about confidence that's why
like if you don't have confidence for
yourself you listen to that it can juice
you up bro the song lose yourself man
like that [__] you know that deserve to
win an Oscar like that song you throw
and Lose Yourself it's kind of a joke
like you hear I remember I can't
remember who said it but someone said
some joke CU like oh the dude was in the
toilet listening to Lose Yourself like
hyping himself up like you listen to the
song Lose Yourself bro that song
actually will make you believe you can
do anything man and then you think about
the actual story like if you seen 8 Mile
like Eminem coming from the trailer park
in Eight Mile Detroit and just off the
back of being a good rapper just having
bars performing and freestyling and
battling every night he literally became
the bestselling rap artist in history
like Eminem is like Elvis for this
generation and that's just off the back
of talent and determination it's like
when you hear Lose Yourself bro that
[__] will actually change your state and
like actually make you ready to do some
[__] bro like I find like if I'm tired
in the mornings and I can get the right
song on bro that will literally change
my state bro like more than drinking a
Red Bull or something you know cuz like
music's powerful you're not wrong stay
fly I play that a lot I remember the
first time I saw the battle scenes in
eight M I got [__] chills down my
whole body you're right you could
imagine being there bro like you just
like CU I've been to hip-hop shows and
I've been to sort of battle type things
but again like where I grew up none of
that stuff was really going on like my
older brother would sometimes like he
was a a sort of he was a rapper he would
like go to rap battles and stuff in
London but like we were living in this
place Bogner and like he would go up to
these rap battles and stuff and I'd be a
kid and always be like man must be so
cool like watching Eight Mile and just
that energy like of being in a in a
venue and like spitting bars and
actually
rapping to a crowd that are like hyped
and like rapping along like you know I
used to I used to rap like I never
really got anywhere with it but I played
a couple shows and performed on stage
here and there and it's a buzz man like
what rappers do and the way that they
actually can like get a crowd hyped with
their words and their ideas and their
thoughts delivered in the right way like
in poetry bro it's just the genre is
just incredible like I got so much love
for it what's up guys as you know
Hamilton devices has been sponsoring the
show for quite some time now and if you
haven't checked out their website you're
slipping if you smoke weed if you like
carts if you like dabs if you like
smoking out of fun stuff go to Hamilton
devices.com and check out one of their
900 items that they have there's
something for every single person and
remember it's holiday season maybe you
don't like Vapes maybe your best homie
does maybe your best homie likes to dab
maybe he likes to smoke three carts at
once blasting in his face if so go to
Hamilton devices.com and if you do use
code dope as usual for 15% off of the
entire site this right here is the kr1
this is a cartridge 21 cartridge bubbler
you can smoke a vape of course why not
smoke it with some water this is the
exact same thing as kr1 except double
you can have a bubbler for two Vapes at
the exact same time this is the world's
first double cartridge bubbler for all
you monsters out there and if you want
to check this out but you also want 15%
off go to Hamilton devices.com use our
code dope as usual at checkout and
that's 15% off once again thank you for
supporting the brands that support
[Music]
us
manscaped it's usually for your
[Music]
dick
do you ever cover any Bay Area artists I
haven't yet man a lot of people been
requesting but I haven't really done it
Dre for us I get I get asked a lot I get
asked a lot to do the MC Dre story man
cuz the way you break [__] down I don't
have to watch eight different other
fools do peace stories cuz you what
you're saying there's a reason why your
shit's 4 hours long cuz you're talking
about everything because there's times
where I'll watch a piece go they even
talk about like four [__] years the
last four years of this Fool's life it
just went to and then on November 1 he
got pass passed away like what about a
successful ass last four years fool so
there be people that cover it but not
enough that cover it well so if you do
it'd be dope I'm down I will do it look
up The Jacka but you know the the
interesting thing about that is it's
like I try and cover a story this
something I've been trying to do over
the last couple years and I feel like
it's what helped me get to the next
level is like when I cover a story now I
try and do it in a way so that you could
still enjoy the whole video if you'd
never heard of the artist at all like
what I've been doing recently is like
not only explaining their whole life
story of the artist but also explaining
the history of like the city they're
from so like if I did the Bay Area like
literally going back into the history of
the city like I just did the young boy
video and I do like 10 15 minutes on
like the history of Louisiana and like
what it's been like for the last like
100 years in Louisiana like the birth of
jazz music and like swamp pop and all
the different types of music that like
different people and immigrants from
kind of all around the world would kind
of like go there and make music in
Louisiana and all the different types of
music that sort of evolved over the
years to all explain like why young boy
now he's making this like very Southern
Louisiana type rap that stands out it's
nothing like the music that like Dirk is
making or like the Chief Keef is making
or the New York rappers are making it's
like Southern and it's got It's like
hundreds of years of like music
Evolution that have actually contributed
to this situation and then going into
like the gang politics of like well why
is like why are poverty rates so high in
Louisiana that have led to these gang
conflicts that boys then rapping about
and it's like like I say if I did the
Bay Area it's like trying to explain it
in a way that someone from the UK that
has never even heard of the Bay Area
could understand and learn everything
about it and then learn like the macre
story from scratch and that's why they
end up being two three hours cuz it's
like bro it might take 15 minutes to
explain like what the barrier has got
going you know have you been able to use
any AI tools to help make your job
researching easier yet no man this is so
funny people keep hitting me with people
saying like oh you know cat GPD is going
to be able to write one of your scripts
and I'm like bro no chance bro my my
shit's complicated like I'm I'm every
now and then like I hop on GPT and I'm
like let me see if I can come up with a
way of it giving me some info but like I
always find I'll ask it [__] and I'll
see mistakes like I'll see stuff that's
wrong like I've been on there before and
been like okay like write me like the
the history of Chief Keef's career or
something and they'll write it up and
I'll be like ah they're missing all this
important stuff and it's like and the
way they've written it's not really like
passionate so for me honestly like I'm
quite skeptical of like the whole AI
thing to be honest I think it's clearly
good for certain things like I found it
useful for certain things if I need to
get a bunch of data that I've got and
put it into a table or like rearrange it
it's great saves loads of time but like
creatively like the way that I write my
videos I do it with a lot of passion and
I think that's where people connect with
it because they can tell I really like
have a personal connection with the
topic or the artist I'm talking about
and when you get stuff written by GPT it
ain't really got that personality and it
hasn't really got that connection I
think people can tell like there's a lot
of these channels especially in hip-hop
like there's a channel called hip hop
daily that's like I can tell that
whoever runs it they got a they got like
a I don't know if it's AI generated
Voice or just like a voice artist from
Fiverr but you can tell they don't even
care about what they're reading they're
mispronouncing rappers names like the
stories they kind of just keep repeating
the same info over and over again and
it's kind of like H this is like a AI
version of what I do and it's like they
sometimes get views they sometimes don't
but like what I'm creating is special
and it's like I have a personal
connection to these stories and like I'm
personally finding the information and
I'm deciding like what's relevant and
what isn't and like what moments of the
story are important and like what new
wants to put on certain things and like
these AI tools like they haven't got
that human touch so I haven't found any
way that I can use them for the research
yet and as well like a lot of the a lot
of my methods that I used to find stuff
quite Advanced like doing Twitter
advanced search or like you know doing
finding finding out [__] on Reddit and
finding like small like communities of
people that are interested in certain
scenes like I I've not looked into it
yet but I'm sure there's like a Reddit
Bay Area hip-hop drill Sub sub community
that like I would want to go to if I was
going to find like the real background
story of like the Bay Area artists and
like GPT ain't really going to be able
to do that and it's not going to be able
to like read comments like for me it's
like like I'll do stuff like if I'm
doing a video on like an old story and I
watch say like a old Chicago music video
I'll read all the comments and then
sometimes the comments might have leads
or like links to like other stuff and
you know that's how you end up finding
like a vlog
from 15 years ago with like 200 views on
it from like a famous artist cuz you
just finding all these little
connections and like GPT at least right
now Ain ain't really able to think on
that level and like go deep and like
find stuff that other people aren't
really going to think about it's it's
very good at giving you the generic
thing that like a basic person would
give you if you got someone to like help
you with a research or something you
know I think people think it's way more
powerful than it actually is it's like
yeah it's a small little tool might kind
of push me in a little direction I've
Got a Theory that
like I just think there's something
weird with AI and the human brain so
it's like for example you know how there
was these websites where you can get AI
generated images right and it was like
oh they're going to be able to you're
going to be able to fake anything and
they did the fake like they did the AI
fake of trump getting arrested yes and
people were like oh it looks real but
it's like now when you look at it you're
kind of like I can kind of tell that's
fake and I can see details I feel like
humans are very good at outsmarting the
AI and people like oh the AI is going to
get so good but I think as soon as the
AI gets good I think people's brains
adapt very quickly once everyone knows
the AI deep fakes are really widespread
I think most of society would just be
like all right well I know I can't
believe a video unless it's looks a
certain way or like if it's pixelated
I'll just I just know I can just tell by
eye that it's not right and I think a
lot of AI images you look at and you can
you can just you don't even know how but
as a human you got that innate sense of
just like ass computer generated like
that's some [__] computer made and I
think uh you know when you watch videos
that have been AI written you can kind
of tell like the way the sentences are
formed and they kind of say the same
thing over and over again and you're
like ah this ain't what a normal like
you know you could never get a AI
generated podcast right like people do
that thing they go on GPT and they're
like oh generate me like five lines of
dialogue for a Joe Rogan and and ASAP
Rocky interview or something and then
you read it back and you're like they
would never say that yeah they would
never go like that it's the chat GPT is
not a con ofur of music it could tell
you like this is the number one hit this
is the coolest one but like the artist
know that's not the best song you know
that cuz you're a connoisseur of music
so it matters it's kind of like when we
do weed videos like you we know that
that shit's going to be fire like oh
that's going to be this because you're
star doing this you're talking about
you're talking about this you're putting
the effort it's on your channel there's
a reason why like you said I'm not going
to do months of research on somebody I'm
like it makes perfect sense that's why
the videos have the appeal that they do
like I I just watched a randomly my
homie was telling me about a guy named R
and then you just did one on the guy I
had no idea thing is I don't know who he
is I don't know where he's from and now
I do every single thing I've never heard
one song he's been in jail the way he
was doing it it's just like it was the
way you did it like this guy did what
and you showed his interview clip of him
like this is all from drug money go what
is happening and then you're like I
don't know if that's pretty you know
that's his decision so the way you're
doing it's like it's not unbiased but
you're also still a fan so it's not like
you're sitting there going hey if
anybody look into this this lyric right
here is another is more you're not out
there putting people out and trying to
get them arrested it's like I said
earlier you're you're a fan you're
reading what you've seen and anybody's
allowed to read that but when I saw the
r thing I couldn't believe these were he
he said all of those things those were
real videos of him saying I bought this
with all drug money bro what are you
doing well yeah crazy what do you think
about like uh the KE going on for
Tupac's murder the same thing thing from
his Vlad TV interviews they basically
like [__] arrested him right like
just goes to show you bro self snitching
it's it's every level you know what I
mean like that guy you know the funny
thing is I think once the media once the
arrest happened like you were seeing
like the BBC were like oh my God like
this guy's finally they finally found
someone for two Pack's murder if you
actually been following the [__] you'll
know like vlad's like two Pack's murder
been solved like Vlad basically solved
two not saying Vlad solved it but like
on vlad's channel he had the answers B
Bally before anyone and like now the
media is like oh this guy got arrested
and oh there's these interviews but like
if you follow Vlad closely you'll know
all this stuff that's been talked about
all this time but it just goes to show
you like there's there's no time date on
that I guess it's like what you guys
call it statue of limitations like you
don't have that over there I think um
you find out I don't I don't think you
do for murder in the UK I don't think so
yeah we don't have it for murder here
either right just certain stuff just
certain stuff I don't even understand
like why that's a thing but I guess you
would like
it's for certain crimes right so
obviously for murder they can get you
any amount of time but drug dealing [__]
scammer [__] I I don't know don't I
don't know but I know drug dealing [__]
for sure is seven years sat limitations
that's a that's a decent amount of time
a long whole lifetime man but yeah the r
story is crazy it's cuz he just got out
that's the funny thing is like um
he he W even away for that long really I
can't remember exactly when he went five
or six years right yeah but like I feel
like
he was dressed on Vlad seems in that big
ass
blueing in the big coat yeah it's crazy
that's a crazy story cuz again it's that
self snitching thing of like he was just
openly like in his songs like he was
like you know talking about yeah we got
this big trap house we call it Pakistan
like we're trapping in Pakistan and he's
saying this in his songs it's like bro
it's only a matter of time before the
feds got you but in a way I think what's
interesting about that story is it's
it's a story of like somebody that was
really just daring like he didn't give a
[__] and he was just like I'm just going
to do this and talk about it and just
whatever happens is is what's going to
happen and like you know he he made a
name for himself and yeah he did his
time in jail but now he's out he's going
to do a bunch of interviews I wouldn't
be surprised if they made like a proper
feature film like some W of Wall Street
[__] about him cuz his life was crazy
he's still around to tell the story like
he's got to be doing like a Netflix or
something you know like obviously I love
the documentary I made on him but like I
could see him doing a Netflix series
about what he did and cashing in Legally
off of what he did so in a way it's
probably worth it and I as far as I know
I don't think I don't remember seeing
like murders or anything involved in his
story it was just big trafficking on
Jets and Counting a lot of money but you
know it's uh it's a crazy like it's just
like one of the craziest stories that
Hip Hop's produced you know these sort
of like drug dealer rappers and since we
have an expert here and I don't know I
see so many people you should uh talk
about this talk about that you should
have this guy on the show you should
have and then obviously some people pass
away you I mean things happen or some
people don't or go to jail people always
talked about King vau I had no idea who
the guy is because I don't listen to I
listen to what I listen to I'm not
saying it's bad I've heard some of it
very very very catchy Super Evil lyrics
about Mur what a storytelling ass
[__] though wow bro you can
listen to a song go oh yeah I saw every
single thing you just said that's why I
like M Dre so much I can picture it all
bro this man is a storytelling ass
rapper and it's it's great a lot of evil
ass lers a lot of murder a lot of
disregard for life which is fine I mean
NWA are talking about shooting fools too
all right so it's just a different genre
I mean a different time I know after he
got killed it was like the serial killer
of rap so this is one of the few times
where it's like this rapper like oh that
guy is dead that guy is dead holy [__]
that so everybody he was really talking
about were already really killed so is
this man just why isn't he considered a
serial killer I consider him a serial
killer personally because like he meets
the definition I know a lot of people
were upset with me saying that and like
I'm really I'm not trying to disrespect
him or be like I'm trying to put DT on
Von's name and call him a serial killer
it's just it's like if you look at the
FBI definition of like three or more
murders in different locations more than
a month apart with like you know various
different motives like bro he meets that
definition if he says that he killed
seven people in hella songs we're
talking at least three songs he
basically says he killed seven people
like he says I got seven bodies bodies I
got a few three plus was it three plus
um like he I think what I try to get
across with that video is it's like
we're in this era of hip-hop where it's
like everything's about realness
especially in drill it's like is he real
he's doing no capping like he's talk
spitting facts on the mic and like
everybody when Von was alive all anyone
used to say is like bro Von is the
realist he really he really B it and
then you listen to the songs and he's
like well he's saying he's got seven
bodies bodies I got several like you
know shoot all the women in here or
whatever and then like it's like well
let's look if he's that that was my my
goal with that video was just like let
me just look into is he capping is it
real and it's just like well what are
the murders people say he did okay let
me look it up the rumors and then the
lyrics and that that I think the area
where the video really went to the next
level was the tweets so I basically read
every tweet V ever made in his life like
from 201 I think 11 when he gets a
Twitter account I just read every single
tweet and then when a murder took place
that he was rumored to be involved in
I'd be like what did he tweet in the
days leading up to the murder and the
time of the murder and afterwards I
wasn't I didn't know what I was going to
find but I looked into it and I'm just
like he basically pre-wwe he was sliding
on people and then he would kill people
and be tweeting afterwards like haha
like who just got smoked or like who
died LOL and [__] and it's just
like it doesn't seem like he was capping
everyone said he was really about it I'm
not trying to disrespect him but I'm not
trying to glorify him either like he me
he met the definition of a serial killer
he was rapping I got seven bodies and if
you look up the people who are allegedly
the bodies he's tweeting all around like
yeah who died who got smoked we're
smoking him and like he literally
tweeted like i' done killed 5 GDs and
shot 10 more and it's just like he was
really about it and if anything it's
like I don't think it's even
disrespectful to say he was a killer cuz
he took great pride in being a killer
like he called himself a demon he said I
got bodies in here like I'm really about
it like test me and all this kind of
stuff like that's the that's the content
of his music and it seems from his own
tweets his own statements like he was
really doing that [__] and like you know
For Better or For Worse I feel he's
probably the like the quintessential
example of like a street rapper that
kept it real and really did what he said
and like you know I don't I wouldn't
condone killing in any situation but Von
really did rap what he said and said
what he wrapped and did what he all that
stuff like that's what it look like so
that's why I think that story resonated
with so many people because it's like
I'm just I'm just laying out the facts
like I'm not saying nothing crazy really
it's like Von that said all this crazy
stuff and I've put it all together few
to look at and you know it tells us it
tells a one-of a-kind story like no
other rapper has claimed to have killed
seven people was he a teenager and all
was going on I think uh man maybe he was
like young I think he was like 18 when
like the first lot killings were going
on I think I think uh maybe he was 17 or
18 when a lot of the shootings happened
it was 2012 he was uh I think he was
born in '94 and like all the first
bodies and stuff was like 2012 so I
think he would have been 18 when all the
like killing and the gang war started
and I think was he 26 when he passed
something like that Dam um but yeah man
like you know it's but again I try and
also take a sympathetic tone like his
father was shot by a sniper in Chicago
by a rival gang like by a sniper by a
sniper so like back in the day in like
the ' 80s and [__] they used to have the
gangs the BDS and the GDs Black
Disciples and Gangster Disciples in
Chicago were like rolling so deep they
used to they basically used to run these
different project buildings and they
would have snipers on the roofs of the
projects and it got so bad eventually
Chicago like they tore down all of these
projects and that's what kind of like
displaced a lot of the gangs in Chicago
because it was like there were a few
project buildings that a lot of these
gangs really took over and then the city
were like okay we're going to shut them
down and then a lot of the gang members
all just had to move to all different
areas and that's what led to like a lot
of violence in Chicago because you had
all these former well organized gang
members just going like Renegade all
over the city and like again these are
the circumstances that Von came up in
I'm not saying like he's a serial killer
he's a really bad guy but like he meets
the definition of a serial killer and he
went through so much [__] in his life
that it made him a killer I think the
point that I try and make in the video
though is it's like I say that he's a
serial killer more so because even after
he became famous he was still trying to
put hits on people and get people killed
and like he took great pleasure in
rapping about having killed like he
wanted the world to know he was a killer
like if he was still alive now he'd
probably be on trial for murder and like
he would be an Infamous killer in jail
living that lifestyle and a lot of these
famous killers in jail you know they
become like prison celebrities right so
he would have been probably living that
lifestyle if he was still here you know
like obviously I don't want anyone to
lose their life um I think it would have
been better if Von had survived and was
still here and you know we'd have been
able to see like maybe maybe through the
court system if he really really really
did all of that stuff but like obviously
unfortunately he's not here anymore and
you know the best you can do his
research and police reports and his own
lyrics tweets MH and it it paints a
picture man it's you know it's it is and
you know no pun intended but V is one of
the craziest stories in hip-hop like
ever I think people are going to be
talking about Von for the next 20 years
like T Pack but in a different kind of
way you broke that down really
well I was just stuck just listen that
well sorry you broke that down very well
I got l lost thinking about for people
that grew up on like that whole first
generation hip-hop you're talking about
who know nothing about King V would
never really sit down and listen to his
music it's the perfect way to really
wrap your mind around the [__] like
exactly because I learned all everything
I know about those [__] is from your
videos you know what's funny because I'm
so into hip-hop and I listen to drill
music all the time I think anybody
that's a big fan of hip-hop and drill
music you're very desensitized to this
stuff it's not it's nothing out of the
ordinary to throw on a song and
someone's talking about I caught a body
or I shot the Ops or I'm smoking this
person but it's like people like my mom
or like someone that doesn't listen to
hip-hop they throw on a king Von song
for the first time and he's talking
about I'm outside your crib waiting for
you I got five bodies like to the
average person that's crazy they never
heard anything like that on a song ever
in their lives and it's like it's it's
interesting it's like I feel like that's
why that story touched so many people
and went so much bigger wider than
hip-hop it's cuz I think people that
didn't know anything a lot of people hit
me up and like i' never heard of V
before I seen this video and now I've
watched the video I've heard a lot of
his songs and it's crazy and it's just
like them people that ain't never heard
anything like that that's never even
heard a Chief Keef song to them V is the
first drill song they've ever heard and
he's talking about I killed this person
we're smoking this person that person
this person that person it mind-blowing
to them and I feel like that's that's
been interesting for me cuz like even
making the documentary I never really
put myself in the shoes of somebody that
never heard of even a someone that never
barely heard any rap music to put on Von
for the first time and it's just
somebody that doesn't talk about murder
every day in their life like that's
that's crazy it is like a full-blown
it's like horror music in a way talking
about so Much Death that it's like it's
like goth I mean West Craven genre yeah
I don't know that many like genres of
like I don't know death metal or
whatever that type of [__] is I don't
know anything about that but like it
probably has that effect on some people
because it is hard and then you know Von
song's like you think of a Von song like
on your ass and he's like just so
aggressive like he's almost shouting
into the mic like I'm on your
[__] ass I'm waiting for you in
your [__] Gra like just it's so
aggressive like you feel like V is like
shouting at you on the song you know
it's it's intense for some people man I
know it's like I make fun of my wife for
watching nothing but Murder Mysteries
and shows and then I'm [__] just
listening to grisela and [__] doing the
dishes while she's watching [__] and
[__] that's my my my homie said that to
me the other day he was like bro drill
music is just True Crime for guys
basically exactly it's facts bro I mean
it's like that's a great
slogan so many more people it's true CRI
for guys yeah that should be on your
banner it's crazy it's like a new
realization but the funny thing is it's
kind of sad in a way is like people kind
of follow these gang members like
celebrities or almost like gossip
magazines cuz like there's a lot of
different especially on Reddit there's a
lot of different subreddits like the UK
drill subreddit people like yo like this
rapper or like this guy that's friends
with this rapper just got stabbed and
then they like pictures at the crime
scene and [__] and they're like oh this
person just got stabbed and then
there'll be like a new there'll be like
insta story and be like Oh back story
like this person caught this person and
then they chase this person and it's
like I was chatting to my mate about it
the other day and they were like man
it's just like gossip for gang members
and [__] CI app yeah the citizens app
yeah it's crazy and you know like in a
way it's kind of sad like that's not you
know that but it's also like I feel like
that's just what social media is
nowadays bro like people want to hear
the latest person that got caught
lacking or like celebrity that cheated
on this person or like you know someone
got exposed by a woman just it's just
like an endless cycle of uh media shig
yeah but but it also boosts people up
like it boosts rappers up I mean people
like you see the whole blueface cron
Rock thing and like that like them
having their relationship drama was just
like boosting up all of their media and
like their subscription service and like
music or whatever it's kind of like you
can see a lot of instances it's promo
yeah yeah it's funny like I don't know
it's kind of like some I feel like for
some rappers it's almost like if you can
get
caught up in some of these situations
it's almost like a booster for your
career you know well it used to be fake
beef yeah remember fake beef but now
it's like we were talking about earlier
it's real now it's real d songs they be
doing fake relationships too you know
what I mean people getting the little
fake fake yeah fake girlfriends and [__]
to like get clout and stuff huh Travis
KY and Taylor swi type show oh is that
what they were doing there's no way on
Earth that Travis Kelsey
goes that's the woman I'm trying to be
oh it's Taylor Swift there I'm sorry I'm
sorry I don't know who that is Travis
Kel Travis Kel is a guy he's a he's a
football player he's dating Taylor Swift
I'm not saying she's unattractive in any
way I'm not saying like oh he doesn't
want to date her I'm saying you're tra I
know people like she's T Swift she can
have any Dude any girl can basically
have any dude like you're a guy yeah but
him it's like you're Travis Kelsey Super
Bowl winning Travis Kelce giant tall man
with money this is America you you're
you're you're good just walk in anywhere
and go hey do you want to go on a date
they're probably going to say yeah
you're [__] on every
commercial I'm not saying girls are dumb
and those day Travis skel but most
people would that's the kind of what it
is like oh he's Rich famous guy yeah
I'll probably date this guy Taylor swis
the most famous apparently is the most
famous person ever now I found out
recently she can date any Dude too cuz
and's like she's she's a chick oh she's
a billionaire do you know what I'm say
so when it comes to that fake
relationship [__] I totally think the
NFL was like yo Travis Kelce we need
people to care again you're now dating
Taylor Swift okay put it like a slice in
your eyebrows so you're like we you
still look tight but date Taylor Swift
like they try to keep him
like you don't want to dayto Swift
Travis Kel I know that the NFL's that's
that's a fake relationship the NFL needs
it cuz nobody gives a [__] anymore about
the football really is it not a thing no
people ain't rocking with it no people
still watch football Ball but I think
it's like uh cigarettes now it's like oh
damn kind of is you smoke sigs still
most people Vape now it's like damn you
still watching football on Sunday holy
[__] what people watching instead like
what's the thing nothing social media
watching [__] celebrity the celebrity
[__] shootouts and King vaugh I
promise you dude I I there's something
about the lack of love for football
and I like football I don't follow it
regularly but like I I kind of like
I've always liked American football more
than like soccer and [__] you know like
I never been that into sports cuz I was
only into hip-hop like that's all I was
into like just hearing like the latest
whatever Eminem was up to or this rapper
or that rapper and watching YouTube and
watching interviews like it's difficult
people always say to me like oh have you
seen this new thing on Netflix and I'm
like n like I'm just watching the new
Lil duk interview or I'm just watching
the new like Breakfast Club interview or
whatever and it's like that's
Entertainment to me so yeah I do kind of
feel that where the NFL coming from like
it's a lot easier to to kick and watch
three King Von videos on YouTube than
like stay up and watch a football game
it just doesn't got the hype it it used
to have I don't know I don't know I
don't know but fake relationship yeah I
think that's a fake one for sure I
wanted to ask just how's your
relationship like with YouTube when you
make the reaction videos with people's
music and all their other video clips
are you in a constant battle with
YouTube trying to get monetized or are
you just kind of good and it's working
for you I've had a lot of ups and downs
with it you know I would say that on the
whole YouTube are like pretty fair and
sometimes it's a case of like I'm def I
spend a lot of time like rereading the
community guidelines and like anytime
there's an update or a change to them
I'll like really read them carefully and
try and think about like is there any
way that like I maybe accidentally
breaking some of these rules with my
content so like at the very start I was
putting like clips of Music in the
videos and like you're supposed to be
allowed to do that under fair use if
you're genuinely doing like a critique
or an analysis of some lyrics but the
copyright system just doesn't allow you
to do it so certain point I just decided
okay no more music in the videos I'm not
going to use any songs I'm just going to
use like I've kind of really recently
tried to shy away from even using like
hip-hop beats I'm trying to use more
like movie score soundtrack like more to
build a Vibe rather than to just like
pick a beat that sounds like the artist
I'm talking about cuz I think that makes
the videos a little bit more Timeless
but like so I don't use the music with
the monetization I've definitely had
I've had a few hits over the years of
like you know having a clip of of let
two rappers having a fight in a video
and getting demonetized and just sort of
not really realizing that like ah having
physical violence on screen is against
Community guidelines so I can't monetize
if that's on so it's like as time's gone
on I've been a lot more careful I did
take a few hits last year where it's
like I got videos demonetized for like
excess swearing and I kind of thought
about it and I do have a lot of these IG
lives where rappers might just be like
yeah F this person F that person send
the nword a lot and it's kind of like if
it's like the fword happening in the
video a lot they will demonetize you so
like more recently I've literally just
been like blurring out the FW the nword
like when people are swearing if there's
a fight on screen just blur it out you
know cut out the audio or like just
being very careful and so like now I do
an uncut version of the video on patreon
so it's just like it's got all the
swearing even maybe a few clips from
some of the songs like cuz the patreon
system is like a lot more fair um so
I've kind of been like doing that uncut
and then just having the YouTube video
like very heavily censored no swearing
and that kind of thing and you know I've
been pretty lucky with it like YouTube
haven't given me too many problems with
monetization recently like I had a few
problems with the Von video it got taken
down and put back up and I had to like
like even now I'm blowing out all the
guns like oh damn that bad it does take
a long time that's that's one of the
problems with it you know shout out my
editors who like frame all that yeah
blur all the guns is kind of long but at
the same time it's like if that's what
you got to do to get monetized then
that's fair enough cuz like this is
something I've really struggled with
it's like now I got over a million subs
and like the videos generally get more
than a million views when I drop and
it's like you know that's having a
million people watch like that's having
like a prime time TV slot or something
like back in the day so it's like and
you wouldn't see people saying the FW
and smoking blunts even at 9:00 p.m. on
TV yeah you wouldn't see someone smoking
a blunt and toking a gun really so it's
kind of like realizing like I have that
responsibility to be like I probably
should I probably should blow out the
guns the blunts the the fword cuz it's
like we it's like we're mainstream now
you know it's like you know try not to
swear too much all right Mar you hear
this right here you hear this and and
the accent you're he's right I know
you're right I have a channel I'm at 1.6
right don't get paid I've never gotten
paid don't get paid for [__] Shadow Bann
block a restricted every single thing
it's the weed it's the weed yeah but
this channel is demonetized too our
podcast Channel because and you're like
well you say the f word too many like
you just said f word you didn't say
[__] I've been trying to edit our Clips
on our Clips Channel I try to go through
and edit them here takes ages yeah
that's the problem man that's the
problem I was explaining this to my my
friend Yuri who got the t-shirt from
last night so who Yuri is is who Yuri
formerly of no jumper he's basically a
live streamer that's right with glasses
he has his own podcast now they say me
and him are the same guy he's got his
own podcast yeah and he does like
regular live streams but I was telling
him he he gets demonetized a lot for for
smoking weed and drinking on his streams
and I was kind of trying to explain to
him like I was like dude it's so
annoying but it's like if you want if
you want the channel to be monetized and
you want your stream to be about more
than you smoking weed I was like you you
need to just like get the weed off
screen like even if you're going to
smoke like you could smoke off camera or
something and it's just like it's like
it's not what you want to do but it's
also like if you want to if you want to
get back into the monetization thing
like that's just what you're going to
have to do like the rules are the rules
and it's annoying but also like I've got
a friend like a good friend of mine in
the UK he's like the biggest UK cannabis
YouTuber called drw sharing oh with the
blond he has blonde now right I think
may maybe he's had a few different
colors but wear's the hats he's always
wearing like was sharing yeah yeah yeah
Drew yeah shout out Drew but like he's
got the same problem like he got
demonetized so he's but he's finding a
lot of other ways to like make revenue
of like doing sponsorships like working
with Brands like in a much bigger way he
was monetized as a we content person he
was but he was getting demonetized a lot
and then he got fully demoned like then
they hit him like they get you
eventually they always get you but like
you know he's like he's doing his thing
and he's I saw him the other day and
he's just kind of like he's like there's
so many other avenues and like he is
like weed is about everything he does so
there ain't going to be a way that he
can like keep the weed off camera and
still do it yep but he does he does
really smart stuff he'll do like YouTube
shorts like viewing stuff and he might
not show the weed he might talk about it
but like he did he did a hilarious I see
him did this funny YouTube short and he
was like oh the best coffee shops in
Amsterdam and he was like I really want
to try and get this video monetized and
he's like yeah this place they got the
best coffee like if you want some good
Cali coffee this is the best coffee I
everything candy on my other channel oh
that's a good shout yeah yeah eating
candy out here I just ate a bunch of
candy but it's still got demonetized man
the other channel they're hot on it man
but that's the thing like you know the
rules of the rules it's just you got to
ask yourself like now that you're big
and like you know this is a mainstream
podcast on YouTube like realistically
you're doing numbers that like a TV
channel would want to do on a lot of
these pods so it's kind of like you got
to think like could I do this and say
this on TV it's like realized about
YouTube though cuz we had a third
Channel completely familyfriendly and
clean oh yeah my they demonetized that
channel just based on him hosting
it and I don't cuss I don't cuss smoke
it's all like cars fun reviewing this
place in La let's go on a hike please
don't swear in the comments yeah please
don't cuss in the comments in the live
chatz I'm always in the live chat
Premier and they still got me but it's
probably just cuz it's me cuz you're
know cuz you're known now now known as
like a cannabis content creator like
you're just in the system that's the
annoying thing cuz they got the whole
thing where they're like oh you're not
if you get banned for one reason like
you can't make other channels like I
can't remember who it was but there was
someone that got banned and then it was
just like every time they tried to make
a new channel New Angle even as a guest
on another Channel they don't let them
back on but like at the same time like
there's also something cool about being
part of the like Underground demonetized
club of weed YouTubers that are like
really cool so you know what I'm saying
you guys got your own thing and you guys
have got other ways of making money so
you know what I mean it's like it's it's
a different you're playing a different
game where it's like I'm trying to be
like I want to be like the the AE
Gangland documentary that's exactly what
you are I even said it's like a [__]
Network MH it feels like a network it's
the editing is seamless everything goes
back and then it goes back to you one
day maybe you'll just be like in a news
looking room I you know I mean my setup
like I got the neon lights like I feel
like that's slow getting better before
you got here I was talking about that's
how I wanted to do well I talked to you
about it I was talking about like my
live setup I just I I have so many
people watching and I'm using my laptop
screen and I still can't figure out how
to change it from to 4K so it looks like
[__] every live I I'm just I'm that dude
and I would like to step it up but for
you I feel like one day it will be that
I'd love to man like like you should you
should that's where you're going that's
where it's heading even just watching
I'm like damn
yeah they edited this and you said oh I
have't team editor like oh thank god
dude cuz that means 24 hours you're
you're there yeah that's the thing
watching it back a 3our [__] video
watching the three-hour video back
that's one of the hardest things man
like you know shout out to my team like
we've all been trying to help and work
out better ways of doing this but it's
like when you get when you're rocking
with like a 6our video and you're like
looking for mistakes like so many things
come up spelling mistakes and then with
the censoring like there been so many
times that I've watched a video back
I've been like a damn there's a blunt
there that I missed oh like cuz you know
what it's like with rappers too it's
like IG live guy's just got a blunt in
his mouth the whole time and it's just
like you just miss it or even you know
what caugh I been caught out a lot of
times on this I'll show like an IG live
and then someone's in the comments on
the IG live being like yeah F this
person and then you're just like damn
like another one like I got sense of
that it's just it's a lot and you know
we have a tough time with it but you
know what I mean we we're getting
through it and you know shout out my
team man they've been working hard so I
really appreciate yeah we've had videos
like he's pulling the car out and it's
like oh was a triple reflection of the
[__] license plate off of this window
two windows back in and it comes into
fre like wait that is my license plate
that is the address to the house oh my
God but you like there's like a
40-minute video it's nothing like yours
fre but stuff it's crazy how much stuff
you don't realize that I've had it where
it's like I think I did I recorded like
the unboxing of my silver silver play
button and you just don't think you're
like yeah do the unboxing you're like my
address is on the package see my home
address right there like like that or
your license plate or your car or like
you know just like you do a little
Snapchat in your car or something and
you're like I just showed my GPS where I
live like oh like there's a million
things man like you can't think of
everything where it's so hard it's no we
everything you just said we deal with
yeah all the in the cars it's always
Reflections and it's always just the
reflection of my [__] license plate
somehow comes back in being aware of
what's outside the window or like where
you're at especially in La coming in
coming yeah like oh we've showed this
place twice now they're going to know
what neighborhood we're in you got to
like I'll like you I'll wait a couple
more blocks then we'll start filming I
always do that cuz you know it's La I
know where you're at just me I'm not
even from here bro you know I had a
crazy one I don't live there anymore but
um when I used to I used to live in
London 2019 kind of times so I wasn't as
big as I was now but I was getting there
maybe had 100 200k Subs but I filmed
like a little skit where I got on like
the balcony outside my house and
literally I had someone hit me up the
next day be like oh I could see your
balcony I know which building that is
you live here and I was just like man
where I live like bro I didn't even
think of that and it's like literally
like one second I'm just like outside
like I think maybe I'll smoke it on I
can't remember what it was but I'm like
on the balcony in my crib and they
worked it out and I'm like bro it's so
obvious it's me I probably had like my
bike in the background like if you're on
the street you could see I got a bike I
was just like bro I can't be showing
anything no lights nothing on your
balconies nothing in your windows
nothing on
your uh in front of your house either
that's why my house looks like plain as
hell cuz inside I can [__] with it
people will know I've had people tell me
my exact building in floor before when I
lived at the the VIN live it's like now
it's the Trap Central every drug dealer
lives in but when I was there I mean I
there was drugs all the time my house
yeah but there was always drugs in my
house but anyway I would see people just
openly vac seal bags from Target just
carrying them like in the elevator
because if I was wanted to I just follow
you yeah like you you got at least 10 at
that spot cuz if you need that many bags
I just came up on 10K at least I'm going
to rob you and that's where just that's
why La is a server like you said it's
it's Grand Theft Auto out here but um
back to what we were saying sorry
Newsroom man maybe it'll be the I CU I
feel like content creators we were
talking about it recently are are taken
over when it comes to people that are
serious yeah cuz I like I use them as an
example that b burnum do you know who
that is yeah yeah he's great come on man
he's just a vine kid making those funny
ass clips now he's an actual a respect
able upstanding standup comedian like he
is an actual standup and he's great so
there are people that can make it from
just I was just goofing off because
there's examp clear examples of like oh
you'll be around for 30 more years
you're fine you're fine so maybe it is
the journalist sayle I haven't seen that
yet like where's that at and
besides well DJ academics is more on the
drama tips he's he's he's a whole
different genre well he's like the king
of the hip-hop news like cuz he's the
biggest hiop news too so it's different
well that's the funny thing is it's like
nowadays like obviously I follow
academics I get a lot of my info from
him it's usually he's just the first
person with the info something news
happened it's on his page but it's like
crazy how to see how much broader I
remember there was that news like a few
months ago they were like oh they found
some UFO in Mexico or some alien or some
[__] like I see I swear I see that on
academics' page first and I'm just like
I'm getting my alien news from academics
like that's crazy you know what I mean
it's like it's like bro bro brunched
into the alien side of the news but it
really just goes to show you how stream
like even like academics or Vlad or no
jumper like you know Vlad isn't Just A
hip-hop platform anymore he doing Sammy
the bull interviews like two LAPD
policemen about the Tupac thing and they
said that who killed him 10 years ago
yeah yeah and and he's talking like
having interviews with like lawyers on
different cases and all kinds of people
it's like all these platforms have kind
of sort of gone beyond hip hop or
they've gotten bigger than just one
thing you know I'd like to get to that
point well like I said earlier like the
Will Smith documentary or like the
YouTube boxing documentary like I'd like
to expand Beyond them but then still do
those videos with like my hip-hop flavor
and like you know cover things in the
way it's like if I did a video on
YouTube boxing I might not it might not
be a hip-hop related video but like I'm
going to have a hip-hop Focus like all
the rappers that have had celebrity
boxing matches like I'm I'm going fit
that into the story cuz that's what I'm
into and that's what I feel like people
are going to enjoy hearing about so it's
like even if I did a story that wasn't
rap related I feel like would have my
cuz all I listen to rap music all I'm
interested in is like rap hip-hop
culture so the videos are going to be
through that lens which I think people
are still going to enjoy but yeah it's
just interesting seeing all these
platforms that have gone so big you know
I'm kind of getting there yeah you know
it's good to feel a part of it and if
you think about
hip-hop it used to be the underground it
is pop culture it is mainstream it is
the number one form of music so when you
think about hip-hop news and now he's
covering aliens why wouldn't he's the
big he's basically the biggest news
outlet for rap music but rap music is
the biggest thing in the world so that's
why blueface and all these fools are in
the news so heavy and all this [__]
because they're the biggest people we
have yeah think if you think about it
like who else is people love gossip and
people love to go oh [__] and that's
what that is that's exactly what that is
most people are reading the headlines
they probably never even heard the
person's music but then they will after
and I think you said maybe start a
little beef in here and get my little it
kind of is the the world of like I need
you just to hear me
I don't care if I have to do a sex tape
at this point that's how people are
doing it I got to be honest because like
I said it's it's the mainstream if you
might I mean I think cardi B is a very
good example of like you were on that
bad girls club or whatever that damn
show Love & Hip Hop and now you are a
grand me award-winning top artist
releasing every like now people see the
formula of like maybe I just got to be a
little while for a minute look at Jersey
Shore all these fols are famous as [__]
now they started off as a like everybody
made fun of them and now it's like
reality TV is just reality now mhm cuz
reality TV is in your phone well the
people the people who are popping the
most now I feel is the live streamers
people that are doing the IRL live
streaming and I feel like that's crazy
cuz it's like it's not it's not drama
it's not like not drama it's not drama
in the sense of like it's not scripted
TV show it's real life like they're
giving people live in the moment real
life [__] going on like there was that
Viral clip what's it uh HS knocking out
John zerker did you see that clip going
around I don't know who those names you
don't know the two live streamers
basically had a fight but it was live on
stream they were in Miami literally
fighting in the street recently like a
few days ago guy with a beard yeah I
think one of them the big guy with a
beard rolling on the street fighting I
know there streamers but it's like um
you know that is just like crazy and
it's like you didn't even have to wait
to read about that on I don't know
academics people were watching that
stream live watching the fight happen
like they were there really watching
that go down they didn't need to read
about it later on cuz they were there
like live seeing it media it really is
bro like people like Aiden Ross like for
a long time I really hated on Aiden Ross
and I was like I don't really understand
why he's so popular like he just acts
sus and I don't really get it but now I
really understand like he's creating
these viral moments like live like he's
getting people together like chess
pieces and creating this almost like
this real life drama and then giving
people a live window into it and it's
like once I understood that I was like
damn it's actually really crazy and good
and cool what like Aiden and all these
people are doing doing live streams I
don't know if it's something that I've
got in my repertoire cuz I kind of do my
documentary thing but it's like I do
really admire it I think that's like the
pop in space right now that's growing L
you also said repertoire and I don't
think you're a streamer I think it's
smart to be a streamer I'm s I'm sorry
speak some
curses that's fact that was a perfect
description of
it that's how I
feel and then you dip it yeah we're all
just like tagged up scratched up [__]
block letters that kid that Meme with
that Asian kid with the pencil that's
how I write I write fast as [__] it
looks like this m sorry we got way off
but sorry yeah this this is this is um
this is I got a headline here real quick
I'm hoping I can get your reaction that
just happened Snoop Dogg allegedly
quitting smoking weed about 3 hours ago
yo I just saw that I just saw that
before I came here bro looked like
somebody died it did it did yeah it did
condolences like when the queen died bro
like it was like a black and white
picture of Snoop just like bro I thought
I was like maybe he's got to be trolling
bro Snoop yeah it's like JayZ returning
from rap he'll definitely just drop a a
weed line he's going to drop no that's
that's what this is I don't smoke no
more but I eat edes is the next post I
guarantee you I'm calling it here today
so you know what day we film this by the
time because of what see that's what I'm
saying we can't film these two weeks out
he said I'm giving up smoke he didn't
say I'm giving up weed M there you go
get guarantee he drops an edible line
with Martha
Stewart that'll go crazy that's exactly
what's going to happen you think come
onug how hasn't that happened they're
tripping I think they're waiting for
tomorrow that's it has to be what's
going on that's a marketing thing if
I've ever seen fake beef fake headline
oh I got to be honest with you bro
snoop's so influential man when I saw
that I kind I was kind of like man maybe
I should quit you know what's crazy I've
seen a lot of people have you seen this
this trend on YouTube for for all you
fools making these videos have you seen
the trend on YouTube why why quit
smoking made me successful how quit
smoking turned me into a
multi-millionaire my life is like shut
the [__] up I hate watching these people
lie to the camera some click I hate
watching it I feel like though some
people just are like that and they can't
get [__] done if they're high like for
me I find I'm a struggle that I've had
periods where I take time off smoking
and I always find those it's harder more
difficult to focus more difficult to
lock in like less relaxed less like
creative you know but not everyone's
like that yeah but not everybody's when
I hear quit smoking weed I think if the
average person smokes like a joint a day
two joints a day
maybe are these people smoking like me
because if I I'm like all right I can
see how it helped you cuz you can think
and you knowz I just smoke a lot of weed
but the average person I don't like you
know what it's their body it's their
pain May does help Sno snoops 50 blunts
a day for the
I get that but I'm I'm I'm talking the
terms of these these genres I'm not
saying like if you say weed smoke messes
you up you're a liar that's not true cuz
I know some people that should not smoke
weed you don't do [__] I get it but you
weren't going to do [__] without the
weed that was my whole thing you also
weren't going to do anything they used
to hit me with that lazy argument I'm
like no no none of my homeboys they
weren't going to be doing [__] anyway
the weed was just here anyway the weed's
like a perfect excuse for not doing [__]
anyway it's like a good
excuse it's the opposite for me it
greases the gear for real man smokes
weed in the morning like coffee yeah ex
power's on at 5:00 a.m. it just starts
going hard it happens to me sometimes
I'll smoke and I'll be like I'm about to
smoke and go to sleep and then I'll
smoke and be like oh it's a great idea
and I'll have to go to my desk I'll be
there for like half an hour an hour
being like yeah new idea like new script
idea like get it all down but I don't
drink alcohol so at all never well no
not never i' I've not drunk alcohol for
like four years I used to drink but like
I don't drink it at all anymore and like
I just find I don't know weed is more
productive doesn't cause us doesn't
cause as much damage than alcohol does
like alcohol would [__] me up shrooms
and stuff like that I've tried them in
the past but it's not something I do
regularly like what are UK shrooms like
they taste like [__] too worse probably
not that good yeah I I tried them uh
people do the chocolate I've not had
that too many times but I I've known
people that get the like shroom
chocolate and stuff and that's meant to
be good or like I've been to Amsterdam
and tried the the Truffles and stuff
there last dumb American question is
Willy Wonka like the [__] out there I
mean when I was a kid I feel like that
was the [__] like the book and like the
movie it's based on it's like it's over
there also like is everything
Cobblestone cuz what the [__] man and
willly WKA everything Charlie was
running through was Cobblestone and Old
Brick that's what I picture yeah hella
Cobblestone yeah yeah twist your ankle
on that [__] if you're not care just
walk into Starbucks you twist your
ankles on a wet day cobblestone on a wet
day bro you might you might lose your
life you got bland food bland food what'
you say what was it bland food might
twist your ankle what' you say mid weed
mid
yeah for real rain every day rain every
day that sounds bomb to me I love I
don't like the Sun what cold weathers I
wear cool jackets all day we we got I
mean there is good stuff man I London's
cool there's a lot going on it's like
very exciting we got like the seaside
like where I'm from Bogner like in the
summer like two three weeks in the
summmer pop in in what's going to get me
to go to cuz everybody wants me to go
everybody keeps asking me to go across
the damn water and go to UK I'm AF I
don't like flying and I don't like
flying over water first off it sucks
what is going to get me there what is
fun to if I if I land in London
tomorrow what is the first thing I
should do as a weed smoking ass fool as
a weed smoking ass fool and I don't have
to go like to craziest weed dispenser
that's not what I'm asking for you I
would say don't go unless it's the
summertime that's what I would say go in
the summertime go in like the peak of
Summer like August hide Park beautiful
Park smoke outside nice Lake you could
go on a little like raft in the lake and
have a smoke like that's beautiful um
you know walk around all the like nice
shopping areas like uh we got like
Oxford Circus like Picadilly circus it's
like Time Square in the UK it's like all
of those places you go into like a nice
restaurant you go to like a cigar lounge
or like just just all the like nice
high-end parts right in the city there's
loads of History you can go and see like
the Queen's guard like the guys with the
horses and like the big hats and [__] go
take a picture with them just do all the
obvious you go to Buckingham Palace like
you can you can take a tour of
Buckingham Palace like I've been there
not for the tour but like I went to an
event there and like you can go in the
palace and like see where the queen
lives and like see all this history like
it's crazy so stuff like that's cool I
was saying would you do anything that
you just said yeah I don't all that
stuff in the summer I'd go to hide Park
like as a kid or like now as a teenager
or like now yeah I would go now like now
like that's the question like would you
do that like if I if now if I go to
London like I go if I went to like
Central London I'd go to like a cigar
bar like a nice restaurant maybe have
like a little little little Vape outside
before I have some like nice food go to
like a nice like classic high-end
English restaurant in London like eat
hell of food like classy as [__]
everything sounds like you're walking
very soft so here's the thing right
British food Blazer yeah yeah yeah you
got to have blazer for effects it's
mandatory but like the um like British
food's very Bland but London's got hella
good restaurants Cuisines from all over
the world like London's very diverse
Multicultural there's like something
from everyone for everyone like every
kind of food you could possibly want I
don't really go for it but like you know
you could go to the theater there's hell
theaters like shows tell you what I
would probably do if I was going to
London now I'd go in the summer spend
the day chill smoke in the park like go
to like a nice restaurant or a cigar
lounge then go to like standup comedy
like you go to The Comedy Store like any
night of the week it's going to be fire
it's very small intimate venue really
fun like if you you go to The Comedy
Store in London like sit at the front
and like get picked on that type of [__]
would be fun that would be the one that
sounds more fun everything you said on
the back half cuz I when you're
describing everything when I went to New
York the museums this is mum new yor I'm
walking at the same speed if I was
walking down the street like oh sick
painting sick painting I'm done there's
hella museums and stuff like that I'm
not that into that like art galleries
that's the type of [__] that like girls
would drag me to on dates back when I
when I live it's cool to look at it but
I'm not the guy's like I'm going to read
every plaque oh wow 1944 like shut that
painting sucks dick bro let me move on
to the next sculpture or something
that's just I feel like I'm like this
there's a lot of that very like
pretentious kind of stuff in London like
loads of Art
and and museums and like I don't know
most of them ain't ain't really all that
like for me like the the stuff to do is
like food shopping you go to hars which
is like I don't know that's like I don't
know what do you guys have that's like
sax Fifth Avenue kind of like a that is
that like a but there like there's just
one of them in the whole country like
you go to Harolds and it's like famous
it's like just one of the most beautiful
like shopping at least fake nice yeah
it's fake nice here like oh wow Beverly
Hills there's [__] drug addicts
everywhere oh wow the Oscars it's in the
middle of [__] Hollywood Boulevard
it's gross yeah like everything's just
like the right angle like I would say
like things like there's a little
details man like are homeless people are
way more friendly and like you know
saying they might they might help you
along Along on your journey you know
what I mean like they might help you out
a quest and [__] yeah you might get a
little Whimsical Quest off you ever
gotten a scroll you know what I'm saying
sometimes you might get past the scroll
from time to time you know what I'm
saying might happen yo I'm sorry I'm I'm
just everything UK is so ignorant over
here we don't have any type of
grasp or balance so I like it over here
though man I like the American way of
life man you guys are more like carefree
and kind of
like I've always like been a big
believer in like the American dream like
in America you can do anything and be
anything in the UK we're very reserved
and it's kind of like if you got Big
Dreams people are like kind of simmer
down a little bit type [__] you know
what I mean we don't have the American
dream like we got very we got very
strong like class system in the UK like
for you to go from being like working
class to like upper class is like like
no it doesn't happen you know like
you're work you're if you're from like a
workingclass area workingclass
background like that's how people see
you if you're like middle class or if
you're like upper class like you know
aristocratic type person like you're
sort of seen as separate and Better Than
People whereas in America there's a lot
more social Mobility like you can become
a self-made millionaire whereas like in
the UK they'll kind of look down on you
you're like new money type [__] you know
so it's like we're very old school in
that way if you make it you're still
[__] yeah man it's that's how they be
parents yeah for real that's insane yeah
like when I went to University man cuz
like I'm kind of like my parents did
okay but I would say we grew up pretty
working class in like a normal household
then I went to University and you would
meet like sons of billionaires and stuff
and it would just be like just a
completely different life experience
like you're just on a completely
different level but it's like I feel the
Americans were the most open-minded like
I had a lot of American friends at
University cuz they were the most chill
they were open-minded they didn't judge
you as like a lot of the British people
from like private schools and [__] that
I met at University they were very like
look down on me they were like oh you
know this is like private school [__]
you wouldn't understand type thing it's
like like the Americans are like just
chill man I just connected with all the
Americans way more how do you feel about
the you guys's prince marrying some dumb
[__] from California I didn't know till
how long ago maybe three
days maybe three days she was watching
some show go suits ago you that [__]
ner to the prince she goes yeah she's an
actress I go she's not from London she's
not English I thought you had to be now
I get why they were upset it's some
actress girl what if she's acting like
she likes this guy she's said listen I'm
still I'm still not 100% convinced if
I'm honest with you bro
she it's crazy the did you watch the
Netflix documentary yeah it's crazy it's
kind of like I don't know if you ever
had time to watch the the like the Megan
and Harry Netflix docs crazy cuz it's
like she kind of came along and then I
don't want to blame her like some people
blame her some people say blame the
family and so the family kind of racist
but like she came along and sort of
broke the family up and like him and her
had to like go off and do their own
thing and it was crazy news in the UK
like the fact it was like Harry was like
kicked out of the family type [__] but
like how do you feel about it being from
there and you know like not being
prestigious and [__] like well where I'm
from we don't condone that I've always
felt like generally I don't care about
them that much like a lot of people in
the UK really care about the royalty
they think they're great some people
think oh they're so bad we should get
rid of them shouldn't pay them cuz
they're paid by funded by like tax money
like my taxes my high taxes are paying
for them to fly around the world in
mansions and only because that's their
family and they're the king they
basically own all the [__] basically
they own the whole thing like the whole
country like loads of the land in the
country is just owned by the king and
queen so they're just president forever
pretty much yeah like it's it's
hereditary right so like the sun will
become king here's the crazy thing that
I this is the thing I don't like right
like we have democracy we have a
parliament we vote we have elections but
the king is still the head of the
country so once somebody wins the
election the Prime Minister has to go to
the palace and bow to the king and
basically ask for permission to be the
government and the king or the queen
always says yes but that's what we got
going on that's what that's what it's
like I W is it cool man all right by you
got bow you literally got bow and be
like you basically like like I'm bowing
to you but like I got voted in cuz the
people it's the people's vote but it's
still it should be arm wrestling contest
for this sh cuz the idea is like so when
you guys have this is going to get like
when you guys make a law in the US it's
like in the Senate right you are asking
the wrong
rule you know more about American
politics but that's what goes down like
I don't know the senate or congress
whatever they do I don't know fully but
like buch ofs vot they write the laws
and then they agree whereas in the UK we
have like like you got the Senate and
Congress we got Parliament and the Lords
Parliament the band no I'm just kidding
like the cigarettes Parliament lights
used put cocaine in the tips bro
parliament's fire they are the
cigarettes you want anyway um anyway
they all vote on it but the King still
has to it gets the final say any law
that becomes in the UK has to get like
the Royal Ascent so the king it's still
the king don't like it they be like
president has that too it's called a
veto okay okay actually did pay
attention in seventh grade I remember
that it's called a veto like yo we
passed it president go nah it's called a
veto okay well basically that's the king
Dan Deo and ain't no one vote for the
king little Danny DeVito that's little
Danny DeVito that's what the king that's
what the king be doing but you know what
I'm saying the Harry and Megan thing is
interesting cuz I feel
like he kind of married her because I
feel like he wanted to be with somebody
that was like a la Hollywood kind of
celebrity cuz he's kind of cele famous
she was famous on suits I feel like and
she was like a model and all kinds of
stuff but like he's had this celebrity
lifestyle as being the prince like he
literally when he was in like high
school he would have Paparazzi outside
of school and [__] so he's dealt with
all this crazy stuff so I feel like it
actually makes sense for him to go and
live this La life life cuz he's had he
Liv out here the C I think they moved
out here they were living in like Tyler
Perry's mansion for a bit or something
there's some crazy story with them right
Canada oh they in can okay so they're in
Canada now they probably that's probably
the best place for them and no one going
to care about them that you should do
Tyler Perry and be like the man that
brainwashed America none of that shit's
funny I watched it I rock with Tyler
Perry man I really I don't like the
movies the movies are kind of that's all
I'm saying but I feel like the business
like the backstory of the business cuz
those movies they are not really for us
they're like for like kids in a way or
like kids they're just I watch I'm like
I've seen Miss dfire Miss dfire is
hilarious this is not Mrs dfire that's
all it's my Grandma loved Tyler Perry
movies for some reason she always
watched them like media and [__] yeah
media goes to church and whatever the
[__] it's called it was like marinstein
Bears so and so goes to the mall so and
so that's how it felt like Ernest yes
Ernest Goes to Camp it was just plug and
play Meda but he's like running things
in Atlanta now right he's got like some
crazy Film Studio like Tyler I think
they say he's a billionaire now a
billionaire off Media bro a billionaire
crazy and he plays media yeah so he's
the most successful actor of all time
he's a billionaire and he plays the part
of his movies and directs them that's
crazy I think he does direct them yeah
he owns the studio as well bro he's like
involved at every level I I take
everything back about brainwash that guy
is just an entrepreneur I watched a good
interview with Tyler Perry the other day
man it really inspired me yeah it's like
we're hearing him just talk candidly
like about all his ups and downs and his
success I was I I never really knew that
much about him but I was like I kind of
really respect this guy like if he's a
billionaire sir I take B back you're
crushing on so many different levels
that's that's hard has he done a bunch
of other [__] outside of Med I'm sure
he's had probably he probably produces a
lot of movies I on the business side he
built a bunch of Studios I think I saw
this interview and he's talking about
like when he leased his first Studio he
was like in so much debt and he nearly
didn't do it and he was like I had to
trust the process and now he's got like
one of the biggest studios in Atlanta
and is like a billionaire and but
hearing his story I didn't know half of
the stuff that he was involved in I was
like I was like damn I really respect
this dude like bro is inspiring I'd
recommend like Tyler Perry man the media
you feel like this guy's dumb because
he's doing the media thing but then you
actually look into it you're like damn
he kind of smart really I've seen 30
Professor I already seen a guy play a
different person in a fat suit and I was
like I never watched my grandma watch I
think it's not for me I didn't realize
all this other stuff that's [__]
awesome it's funny though how these same
ideas just keep happening generation
after generation like the Eddie Murphy
thing just gets remade and it's like a
whole new generation of people pref like
prefer that and then just learn this new
version of it you know some next dude is
going to do it as well probably in like
30 years he'll be dressing up as grandma
again no I he my little my 9-year-old
boy walking around hi my name is like
all the little quotes are just little
Tik Tok the 90s coming back too though
oh yeah they a lot of and Tik Tok is
really bringing back older [__] yeah lot
of this retro I see a lot of these
Nostalgia pages on Instagram of like I'm
just like oh I remember that oh damn old
yeah the 2000s ones when I see the stuff
like being a kid in the 2000s I'm just
like man that's just that's how it was I
remember those toys man we were just
talking about tomagotchi the other day I
would kill mine I'd overfeed and just
die did you have tamagachi out there we
have Tam yeah hell yeah hell yeah did
you guys ever have uh did you guys ever
have talk boys the little tape record
thing oh yeah that I think they were
called Talk boys or like think Kevin
mallister had
yeah yeah yeah bro I used to like record
little freestyles in that when I was a
kid man that was bro little rap shows I
was like recording Eminem off the off
the radio and [__] it's crazy bro those
things slapped me and my sister used to
do VHS and we record live TV and clips
yeah hell yeah so we'd have oh sick ass
commercial bam the new MTV uh World
release of something with TRL bam sick
ass uh Dexter lab it was like a well you
were recording the commercials not the
shows SI no if we wanted a sick
commercial I love this we car Network
okay you know Nickelodeon like oh I love
that Comm oh sick all right stop and
then be miss the Elliot out of nowhere
it was sick dude my sister had some
those they were [__] tight she made a
whole commercials one which was dumb but
that's basically what YouTube videos are
like 90s commercials for two hours
there's a few channels I forgotten the
name of it now but my my homie was
showing me this channel the other day
and it's basically a doc it's like my
channel like a documentary Channel but
they make documentaries about like lost
media so like old VHS tapes from the 80s
and like old TV shows that have been
forgotten and then like breaking down
all the like crazy history behind these
shows and stuff I forgotten the name of
itting people will be able to find it be
so much there's so much there to like
pull from anybody that's going to do all
the research for me I want to watch that
yeah but yeah I want to know about that
I am not researching that [__] and I'll
just watch your channel like all this I
never heard of that rapper but that's go
that's the good thing I feel like that's
what I'm doing is it's like if you
wanted to learn everything about King
Von before me you would have to spend
three months re doing all the research
be an active fan that's on everything
for since the beginning yeah I'm like
making that information like a aable for
everyone and just like you can become a
Super Fan in like 4 hours and like learn
everything and then you're going to be
caught up with me and then we know all
the same
[__] is there a gisala video on the
works you know what it's on my list I've
wanted to do it for a while but other
stuff keeps coming up but I definitely
want to cover it I know I get it
requested so many there's a few names
like the the Griselda one the macre one
um people keep recommended me who's that
other guy um for for two Doug as well
but there just a bunch of names that
keep getting recommended but I'm
definitely going to do giselda it's just
I got to fit it in there's just so many
this is the hard thing so many ideas I
want to do and they take months so it's
like got to pick them really carefully
damn I'm trying to speed it up man it's
hard it could very easily turn into a
thing where it's like we're doing four a
year that's what it's been like this
year man I had so many slip UPS this
year I was supposed to I was supposed to
do yeah that's the thing I've kept I've
been building my team I just got like
two new people so hopefully it's going
to be all good but it's like I wanted to
do a video every month like I've got
scripts and stuff written for new videos
but it takes so long to put together
this year had a lot of slip UPS so it's
probably going to end up being like four
or five videos this year but next year
man trying to get
monthly ideas oh man I want to do it bro
I want to do it is it hard to pull short
form content out of it because it's like
such a big story yeah I I've had a few
people it's been such like hit and miss
with it I've had a few people make
shorts out of my video and like some of
them have done well some of them it's
kind of been like it just doesn't really
like it's like when you got a 4-Hour
video it's kind of like the whole point
is it's like I'm breaking everything
down really carefully so even if you
take like one minute or 30 seconds of
that video it's such a like small
snapshot of what's going on that it's
like doesn't really work I feel like a
short would be better if if I could
almost like tell the whole story in two
minutes or in one minute in like a
trailer in like a trailer yeah like a
like in a way it's like to give you as
much information as I possibly could in
one minute to tease you into the video
but that kind of that that's then its
whole its own thing and it's like I just
spend all my time working on the the
next video that it's like I feel like a
is that is that really worth my time but
like maybe it would be or maybe like I
could get someone in my team to like put
it together but it'd be cool to have a
bunch of shorts to like promote the
video and like get people hyped you know
has been has patreon been like a a big
part of the process now are you liking
it or yeah now it has like for a long
time my patreon was really like an
afterthought and you know I never really
like had that many people on it or like
I didn't really give them much value and
then only over the last like year or so
since I did a video on like the Toronto
drill scene like a while back and that
was one of the first videos where I did
like uncut version on patreon and I
actually put like I put a lot of effort
in making sure like the uncut version of
the video was like different and it had
a lot of extra stuff like so now I'll
try and put like I think my last video I
dropped maybe there's like 10 or so
minutes extra content in the uncut
version of the video and it's like
obviously it's you know the swearing and
the violence and the guns but also like
there might just be like extra bits of
information that I kind of feel like you
know what I don't want to point the
finger at somebody too much or like I
don't want to
um I don't know be so negative about the
topic but like maybe I'll just give a
little bit more of my thoughts or like a
little bit more analysis on the patreon
version of the video to just be like I
don't know to just give people that
extra value and give people a bit more
of a closer connection to me and like
give a bit more of my take um and like I
feel like I've seen the patreon growth
like slowly increase where I've been
giving more value cuz before I just it
was just like oh do you want to just be
a member of me just cuz you like me and
like no one really [__] with that but
it's now it's like
you know here's a special version of the
videos just for the patrons sometimes
I'll do a little patreon exclusive or
like I did like four little random
videos just on like little mini stories
on patreon like a few months back that
would like they were kind of non-hip hop
stories and they were all stuff that I
couldn't do on YouTube so I had like it
was kind of like fight analysis like
there was this one clip that was viral
of like a smoke shop that got robbed and
then the guy running the counter like
stabbed the robbers and like chasing out
the store you see that well yeah we know
all about that you know all about that
yeah damn well I did like a breakdown of
that video cuz I found like the
backstory and like the it's crazy like
the a bunch of people went and left
reviews on like Trip Advisor for that
store being like Oh yeah great store but
like the guy behind the counter stabbed
me up and [__] like funny stuff but it
was like I found all this stuff about
that story and like put together like a
10 15 minute breakdown just on patreon
cuz it was like it was it's a violent
story we've watched that video 900 times
because we we're convinced he's reaching
for My Vapes really
just like my box it has the same font
and I'm like but I can't cuz you know
it's kind of far when he's reaching for
it and when it falls my I designed that
box that's like that's the Box unless
someone's biting my [__] that's our
[__] that's my vape I was like oh
[__] man that's terrible and then he
goes I'm dead yeah he didn't die though
they didn't oh [__] he didn't die I
think they lived yeah oh thank God man
this whole time I was like oh [__] you
guys dead over this he did say that talk
about this for a long I'm dead that's
the best play dead [__] I've ever he's
getting I'm dead they were young though
I think it was like 17 and two 16 or
something for sure but um to say I'm
dead while you're getting stabbed is
nuts yes Noll that's why you shoot me
Dad it's like a Chappelle bit it is
remember that that's the key to keeping
the show fresh I'm dead I don't want to
leave any
Mysteries oh [__] um well so where can
everybody find your content YouTube Trap
La Ross that's the main Channel um I
also have a second Channel trap more
Ross if you want to get a few little
extra bits of analysis I'm going to be
kind of using that channel to put more
like little shorter documentaries up
hopefully like over the next few months
I'll have a few just little mini stories
there and I got third Channel trapl
Clips where I do like stream Clips I do
like streaming I'll put clips from my
main videos up there that's just way to
like keep up with me dayto day so those
are my three channels and like trapl or
on Instagram kind of update Twitter oh
Trap La r on Twitter I don't really use
Twitter like that but like start using
Twitter I know what what should I do bro
what kind of stuff should I put you I
would for you I say you post a
picture of a rapper post a picture of
someone you've done music for or an
article about or a journal a video damn
I can't talk right I would say like have
you seen this video with the link and
then maybe if it's like of
violent story maybe a you can tost
whatever you want on Twitter yeah so
maybe you could post like something a
little more wild maybe a clip from what
you're talking about and then like the
video video out now that's something
like what the [__] someone's get this is
a crazy ass video who is this fool then
you click the link go oh it's a thre
hour documentary about it and you're
going to get so many people at 2 in the
morning go oh [__] I'm going to watch
this whole thing till 5 [__] cuz that's
me and it could be you sitting there
with a blunt talking about it
yeah on Twitter on Twitter you can do
whatever you want yeah I see people
doing little interview shows and posting
like actual embedded videos on Twitter
now right I get on
that full length episodes actually yeah
we post a full length episode on Twitter
yeah you can get add revenue on Twitter
now too right yes yeah that's
interesting you should do it just
because you are it takes you you're
you're well spoken just put a caption
maybe two artists that have a [__]
beef that you've done a video on MH you
can take you've done every beef on every
single thing on every NB NBA young boy
like all the beefs yeah maybe get like
five of them and put his picture with
this the story of blah blah blah it can
go to the same picture I me the same
video those are all just those oh it's
going to keep going I think you can hit
viral moments maybe talking because what
you're talking about it's pop culture
now rap is the most popular genre of
music so what you're talking about is
like saying Madonna's got a new
boyfriend like this guy just diss this
guy it's the just as [__] popular now
it gets shared just as much because
that's what's popular so I think with
you on Twitter you can be a little more
grimy you can do a little like show a
little more wild [__] that you would not
put on your Instagram you got to blur it
out put it on patreon maybe you play a
clip just full-on clip of something
you're talking about and then you're
captioned on it that's how it would take
the direction for Twitter because you
can do and say whatever you want on
Twitter as long as you're not being
hateful or something about like
threatening people and I don't think
you're going to do that yeah that's a
good idea could put like Clips some of
the music clips or like even like link
to the song cuz that's the one thing
that sucks of that you can't really do
on YouTube is it's like I can't talk
about this song and play you what I'm
talking about and I feel it would just
add so much even if it was like what I
would love something I really would love
to do uh down the line is create like a
Spotify podcast type thing but have it
so that I like explain the history of
the song and then you play the song but
you the song actually plays on Spotify
if you know what I mean so it's like the
artists can have their money like don't
like don't take my video down for the
copy and [__] I want to explain the song
you play the song get youram and then
like I'll explain the next song and then
we'll play that song you can hear the
whole thing radi that's what I'd like to
do yeah I'd love to do that but I
haven't worked out a way of doing it yet
so like maybe down the line I'll kind of
get the the setup for that but I feel
like that would be the best way of me
doing like a podcast or something like
that type of thing where I could
actually Break Down lyrics yeah of
course uh one video like what that I
thought was really funny how trap Ross
made $10 million for you too what was it
so you did a third person for the first
couple minutes of it I'm like yeah I was
like not knowing what to think and then
it just keeps going it was a April
Fool's video that's the thing if you
didn't see the date the video was
uploaded a lot of people have hit me and
being like Oh well like but it's like
it's like the things that I say get more
and more ridiculous as the video goes on
as a child I was a pen pal
Tupac so you know what that's an inside
joke around that time I basically
dropped like two or three videos and I
just had these little clues in it that I
was friends with Tupac and then the next
year for April fools I did another video
I don't if you've seen it but it's like
how Tupac faked his death so it was
basically at the time I I just had this
thing I was I want to do April Fool's
videos cuz it was like it was so easy
for me to do a fake video like I could
make fake headlines fake pictures and
[__] and then I could still make a
10-minute video I was like it was really
fun to me as like a break from doing
actual content so like there's this
other video if anyone checks this out
how Tupac faked his death and I
basically take like
all of the conspiracy theories about tup
Pac still being alive and [__] and then
I basically present all that evidence as
if it's real and then I'm like cuz like
there's like a there's footage of like
Suge Knight drunk at a nightclub talking
about Tupac still alive in Cuba like we
talk all the time and [__] and it's like
that's in there there's this crazy guy
that made this documentary trying to say
like Tupac's still alive and that he
actually like they faked his death and
they took him from the hospital in
helicopter and flew him out to the
desert and then he went to Cuba and all
this stuff and so like those videos are
all kind of connected of like me being
friends with Tupac and like me my fake
April Fool's video but if you didn't see
the date you wouldn't know but there's
basically like I don't do it anymore cuz
like back then that was when I was more
doing like the comedy like that was
probably like maybe I was still doing
stand-up comedy or something at the time
and it was like I wanted to do these
sort of like funny fake videos to like
to just build up like the law around
like what I do and like put more of my
personality in the videos but I kind of
want to do I've got a couple ideas for
other April Fool videos I want to do in
future but I won't I won't spoil fun but
there's a couple ideas I got that are
kind of like I mean I I'll say this one
I won't do it but I always wanted to do
one where I was like oh me going to meet
Tupac like actually that's a great Ender
of this Saga though like fly to like me
like do a vlog like I'm going to Cuba to
meet Tupac and I was like I could get an
actor or something to like play him but
then I was kind of like I I feel like
it's a little bit disrespectful to go
all that that far like making a video
where I talk about the conspiracy
theories is one thing I was like if I
get like a two pack look Al light yeah
it's kind of like but if you're go and
you have all these Adventures but you
never like while you're waiting to meet
him he's kind of never shows two days
pass he never shows up but all this
crazy ass [__] happens that would be so
funny if I was like bro I texted two
pack every day didn't show man like and
why you're sitting there you have a
biggy small as person walk by don't ever
mention
[__] and that's going to get at 1501 did
you see behind him now that's the April
fools like I never met Tupac but you did
you see the biggest smallest personated
at 1501 see this another one of my
videos I can't even remember which video
it is but there's a video where I did a
skit right at the end where I like the
video ends and then my phone rings and
it's two pack and I pick it up and I'm
just like yo mavelli what's good bro and
it's just like just this random like
it's like after the credits like the end
of one of my video I literally can't
remember which video that is but there's
just been a bunch of little Clues over
the years like me and two pack of
buddies cuz I have this fake in that 10
million video I've got this fake two
pack CD that I did a fake autograph on
it's like two rths like big UPS from
your from your homie two pack and I've
got that frame on my wall in my studio
and hella people when they come around
my house they're like they're like whoa
you knew tup Pac and I'm like bro
no yeah you would have been like not
even Bor right yeah I would yeah I think
I maybe would have been like one I don't
was it like 92 96 96 I'd have been three
when two pack died man that would have
been weird that's a funny little Easter
egg though but it would have been like
yo I got around when I was a kid like I
knew people I I was rocking with two
pack Michael Jackson you know what I'm
saying don't ask why
but Jesus Christ brought the whole back
to the Seas Jesus Christ on the dot good
[__] literally 2 hours later on the dot
yes it um so we got to get on Twitter
trap L Ross your Instagram trap L Ross
trap more Ross trap Lor Ross Clips did I
get all that yeah that's it that's a lot
yeah and do the Spotify we love Spotify
yeah I want to get on there man a lot of
people have said I should just turn the
videos into like podcasts and put them
up there I need to do it just put it on
his audio just clip out the the video
Parts I need to literally just go and do
that that's one of those things man it's
like True Crime for guys that's what
your podcast should be called True Crime
for guys bro that's the thing man True
Crime for the
streets or something I don't know True
Crime for guys better it just sounds
funny it's kind of like a manscape feel
manscape sponsor the whole thing True
Crime for guys doesn't mean your dick
has to be
dirty yeah crime to have a Dirty Di it's
a crime to have a dirty
dick all right sorry that's how we
that's why we're not monetized I know
that's why you're not mzed May that's
why we're sponsored by manscapes yeah we
are shout out to manscapes man they give
me a few deals too hell yeah um but
thank you so much for being here what
else you got planned while you're here
man I appreciate you having me I got a
few a couple more interviews that I'm
trying to do be doing cam Capone later
on so you know what I'm saying I feel
like I want to join the ranks of the
greats that have been on cam Capone um I
should be doing no jumper I don't know
all the plans yet I'm kind of I don't
know everything's a I'm just waiting for
the next phone call to come through for
the back for the the bat signal to come
up and I'll go and talk some [__] for a
few hours and do my thing but it's been
a pleasure to come here man I've wanted
to come here for a minute and made it
happen man so it's been lit appreciate
you thank you thank you Marty anything
else we appreciate it man we the first
one to come in fresh out from another
continent land and come shight to the
studio right worldwide man the most well
spoken person we've ever had on the show
everybody thanks you for the yeah that
the audio quality of your speech yeah
thank you very much but no on top of
everything everybody go check out the
videos you don't have to be a fan of the
person I didn't know who R was till it
was done I had no idea who that guy is I
mean I haven't heard his music yet it
was yesterday I watched that one but
still like you do a very very very good
job the editing team you have is
crushing it and it's I can sit there and
I cannot believe some of these are hours
long it makes me feel like oh we thought
we were tripping with 50-minute videos
you're going hard and the fact you say
it takes months makes perfect sense
these are Date Line specials that's how
I that's how I look at them they are
dayline specials for the people that
dayline would never want to talk about
yeah there's the next slogan I feel like
that's that's what I love man it's like
I would want to watch 4H hour video
about Von or young boy or you know what
I'm saying no one's doing it you know
what I mean I wish that I wasn't me so I
could watch my own videos but you know
what I'm saying watch one back man I
watch them back but it's cuz I know
what's coming because I wrote it like in
it it's so weird like I don't know man
like watching your own pods never hits
the same when you you're there you're in
it it's kind of like I think I'm I'm I'm
always we always do the live chat during
the episode and we're always high as
[__] I don't remember everything we talk
about so sometimes I'll be like always
did talk about this holy [__] while
we're in the chat I'm cracking the [__]
up episode's a surprise it's always a
surprise for me I don't edit it he edits
it I go oh [__] we said that Will
Smith's not going to like up we had a
whole thing about you know Will Smith
the whole debacle yeah and we say he
needs to go bang the along openly
publicly be like yeah I banging along
yesterday and then everyone's like
you're the [__] man again Will Smith
Jaden pink Smith a [__] that's what I
think is going to redeem him so in your
in your documentary hopefully by then B
KN along feel free to use that yeah feel
free to use our
predictions right I'm manifesting him
dunking on [__] publicly because
everybody right now is like Will Smith
that's how everybody feels right now he
always comes through man though Will
Smith he does independence day he's
going to it was a rhetorical question I
know you
that um thank you so much for being
sorry that we never end the show but
thank you so much for being here
appreciate you uh from Marty I trapal
Ross thank you so much have a oh [__] I
was about to say have a dope as day to
him I'm burn as [__] guys thank you so
much for being here from Marty travel
Ross and I have a dope as day oh yeah
these These are good yeah they're nice
man they're good I'm feel man I realized
after that first one I'm like damn this
strong that was fun guys appreciate
it right now we're going to announce the
winner last week honor our social media
so make sure you follow our Instagram
that's dope as usual podcast we did a
$300 gift box of raw basically the
biggest gift box of raw you can think of
and we said leave a comment what's your
favorite product we got what across four
platforms 8,000 comments of people
trying to enter this and we appreciate
you guys we went through every single
comment and we picked the winner so
congratulations we're going to start
doing this a lot more often with all of
our sponsors so thank you guys for
entering the giveaway we appreciate you
shout out to the winner 300 $1 gigantic
box of raw so remember if you want to
enter any of these giveaways you want
your chance to win and you already watch
the show follow us on Instagram Twitter
Tik Tok we're going to be doing this a
lot more often thank you so much thank
you for watching this long ass episode
it was super fun super informative thank
you guys have a dope ass
[Music]
day perfect
perfect